hello and welcome to this evening's
meeting with planning and development
management committee
um just to introduce and stuff my name
is aidan williams nasser who's the
committee chair of the committee
also present on the call uh the
committee vice chair councillor ben
hartley
officers from the council's planning
service council's legal
and democratic services the local
highway authority as well as the elected
councillors who make up the member
the voting members of the committee and
before we continue i should
advise reference information that this
meeting has been live streamed and
recorded
so please mute your microphones to
minimize background noise
if you wish to speak on an item please
use the chat facility to notify me
and then wait until you're invited to
speak turning to the
agenda now um attendances
been we have received apologies from
simon
thomas and barry wins stanley um
substitute members
serving on the committee tonight our
councillor aquila canola and councillor
david acton
and thank you for so dooming um agenda
writing two
declarations of interest are there any
members who need to make a declaration
yeah um when we get to 83 white clay
avenue
um i've had no involvement with this
application or the applicant
or residence about this application but
the property actually um is
puts onto my properties is sideways onto
my property so
i'm very close to it so i think under
those circumstances you could argue i've
got a
personal interest so when we get to that
item
um i won't take part in the discussion
or vote
okay thank you councillor um ms coley
you've indicated in the chat that you'd
like to make a declaration
yes thank you chairman uh i'd like to
declare an interest in
the application at mani halal meat and
vegetable shop at moss lane in hale
please
i reside in the vicinity i'd just like
to confirm i've had no
involvement in the preparation of that
the report in front of members this
evening
and i will step out the meeting at the
appropriate time as well thank you
that's great thank you um i should
myself also make a declaration
of interest in the two of the items
um the developments in part in turn um
i i'm with the registered provider of
social housing
that um potentially um maybe working
with the applicant
so i i will not be participating in
those items and uh councillor hartley
will assume the chat
um i can't see any
other counselor rigby yes i'm
interested in the two partings and
applications i was chairman of governors
of three of the schools um
i'm now chairman of members but i i will
be taking part of no other interest
um thank you councillor
okay and moving forward jen's waiting
three
minutes they've been circulated and
there are many
members happy to propose in the second
those
happy to have a second proposal
and counsellor focus yep great thank you
we'll take them
first generating four questions from
members of the public none have been
received
and so we shall proceed to
the additional information report which
ms cody has circulated to members
earlier today um agenda item sticks
which is a
report on developer contributions
towards the carrington relief road
i believe mrs coley are you um just
providing a short introduction to this
thing
uh yes yes jeff you just bear with me
while i share my screen that
this this will be um brief
okay
our members able to see that great okay
um this is a short report which just is
just provides an update really to a
previous report which came before
members of the
at the planning committee meeting at the
15th of october was approved
um in relation to um
using section 106 and still monies to
fund the carrington relief road
and that methodology uh members will
need to note and approve the content of
the report this evening there will be a
vote in the same way as there was for
the previous report
um however the principles and
methodology for calculating the
contributions from that october report
are unchanged
all this report does is simply correct
an error in the calculation underpinning
the formula and i'll just
show you which one where that is so
that's the methodology calculating the
contributions
and highlighted in red is the cost of
the infrastructure
that's where the that's where the error
arose in the in the previous report
um so the body of the previous report
made reference to a funding gap of 12
million pounds for the current relief
road for which sexual analysis
contributions were were to be sought uh
which we didn't
uh couldn't be covered by other means
that's being the cost of the
infrastructure now that could obviously
go up
up or down in different circumstances if
you were to apply this to something else
um however the calculations lying
behind the both the um
calculations in the table in the
previous report and in the
um and in the works example had used 10
million pounds as that figure
erroneously um so all this report does
is correct
that figure uh to use the 12 million
pounds
and therefore sets out a new set of
calculations
sorry contributions per 100 square
meters or residential units
and this revised calculation will be
used um
to seek contributions effect with
immediate effect is actually the basis
of the calculation
of the agreed contribution for the paul
lane partington
application which is to be considered
elsewhere on
on this agenda um thank you that's all i
have to say on that thank you
thank you miss coley um members will be
quite familiar with them the issue of
council really vote now i think
i'm not sure if anybody has any
questions but the the item will need to
be
um voted on by committee to confirm that
it's been received
um i'm happy to propose that we accept
the report
i think i think councilman jerome has a
question chairman
cancelled
sorry um yeah i'm afraid i do have
problems with this report and the
increasing cost to this scheme
this scheme will potentially create an
access link which will bring heavy
volumes of traffic through partington
and carrington
this will increase levels of pollution
to residents
and will increase traffic volumes there
is still no approved route
no consultation and no clear definition
of this project
yet we are agreeing to increase
developer contribution to a road project
as far as i know we we have no
ecological impact study or on pollution
levels in an already industrial area
yet alone our climate emergency we will
see application after application in
partington and carrington where we see
no or little developer contribution
going to public transport
active travel ecological mitigation or
local immunity infrastructure like
doctors chemist schools
i would ask is committee to seriously
think about what we are agreeing to here
it seems that we're going to be giving
even more money or even
more developer contribution to a road
scheme
sanctuary
i'm not miss calling can you clarify
what we're actually voting on here
it sounds a bit as though um
and i don't want to misrepresent you
here councillor jerome but it does sound
a bit as though you're asking us to vote
on the very
concept of the relief road i think
really the report's essentially the
notings
well for recognizing
yes that's correct chairman um the uh
route of the relief road be subject to
public consultation
would require a planning application and
would need to go through
due process there's obviously other
processes that would need to be
involved in determining uh
the allocation of still monies and that
sort of thing through the executive
or committee being asked to note tonight
and the reason it needs a vote is
is just to show that you are noting and
approving that
is that there was a mistake in the
previous report
in the in the appendix the body of the
report had the correct figure in it
um but it does need to be corrected and
corrected form formally through this
means but it is no more than that for
this particular item
chairman i'm happy to second um the
report okay well the report has now been
moved and seconded um
i'll be happy to does it require a full
vote
i'm advised that it does yes chairman
okay um i'll just move your members as
you appear on my own screen and
counselor big biggie
thank you counselor uh councillor jerome
thank you councillor councillor kirby
uh for the report please chairman thank
you councillor
councillor hartley thank you chair in
favor of the report thank you
thank you councillor councillor minis
voting well eventually i don't think
this is about whether you can go for
against the report i thought the report
is as it is and
we're voting to acknowledge it so i i
also acknowledge it thank you
thank you uh councillor morgan
for the report chair thank you
councillor councillor canola
oh thank you council councilman
be the recommendation thank you
counselor council accordingly
uh for the recommendation to change the
calculation
thank you councillor councillor dr
berkley that's the recommendation from
the report
thank you council council for the report
chair
thank you that report has been accepted
by the committee
um moving forward agenda item seven is
applications
for permission to develop the first
applications that are going to be
considered this evening are those that i
have declared an interest in
uh consequently i will not be stepping
down from the chair and leaving the
meeting
and councillor hartley will be in the
chat thank you
thank you chair um we'll we'll move on
to
the two items in partington so uh first
of all there's the
uh there's the land off hall lane and
that's also then the
the second one which is the land joining
the monster ship canal so
first one starts on page 33 of your
bundle and the second one on page 106 of
the bundle
and the proposal is that we take both
those items together so they are
two separate applications first one is
for um full planning permission the
second one i think
is for reserved uh matters um
having previously been an outline
application so
my suggestion is we'll take both those
items together because it's
essentially one development that's being
uh proposed and certainly when i went
through the applications i was noting
down
you know the same points for um for both
applications
um presumably um
miss coley i'd be advised on this or
maybe um the
solicitor on the call could advise would
still need to do a vote on each
application i'm assuming at the end of
the debate
yes that's right you'd have to take um
separate votes for each of the
applications
okay thank you so we'll have we'll have
one presentation we've got
um two two speakers uh against the
development so there's one
essentially against each application and
then we'll also hear from
the uh agent uh for the developer
he will speak to both applications so
i'll allow him
six minutes to uh to speak to us and the
two objectives will will have three
minutes because they're speaking to
an application uh an application each um
so first of all we'll have a we'll have
a presentation on on both applications
uh from miss lowe's ms lowe's if you're
on the call
yes thank you chair um i'll just share
my screen now
is that visible for everybody yes it is
yeah thank you
thank you yes as um council hartley has
indicated this presentation will relate
to
both applications um in partington this
evening
the land at hall lane and the land
adjacent to the manchester ship canal
just bear with me a second my
presentation appears to
gone awry
sorry give me a second
so
so
would you like me to have a go at the
screen sharing it sarah if it's not
working for you
it's just loaded up now so hopefully
that's going to work but yes
if it doesn't come up in a second that
would be really helpful thank you
rebecca
okay okay i've got it up now
sorry about that
okay hopefully that should be up for
everybody now and we can move through
the presentation apologies for the delay
there
so the development here relates to um
the two sites that we have before is the
landsat hall lane
and the land adjacent to the manchester
ship canal to the north of lockley
and what the development here would see
is the provision and the redevelopment
of the whole site and the provision of
449 residential units
the development consists of dwellings of
tooth
detached terrorists and semi-detached
with a maximum
height of 2.5 stories but the majority
of them being a standard two-story
dwelling
the tenure would be a mix of social rent
affordable rent shared ownership
private rent and market sales the
development would see
extensive landscaping across both sites
including the planting of 390 trees the
provision of five areas of open space
a neighborhood-equipped area of play the
provision of a green loop
which would include the formation of a
pedestrian promenade
along the canal side and wider
connectivity improvement works of both
sites with the wider partington area
the developments also provide
contributions towards the carrington
relief road
education provision highways
improvements
and provide 117 affordable housing units
with a mix of
10 years these two applications are
submitted in conjunction and will be
built out as one development
there's a full planning application for
hawley and a reserve matters
and application for the land adjacent to
the ship canal to the north of lachlan
the lock lane site benefits from an
outline planning commission
for up to 550 residential dwellings
and the principle of this development is
previously being accepted
what we're considering tonight is a
reserve matters application
which seeks approvals approval for the
details of scale
layout appearance and landscaping only
the plan um on the screen now shows you
the extent of the combined sites
the whole lane site uh to the to the
south
east of the site and then the lock lane
and continuing in a linear form
all the way down and adjacent to
to locklear both sites are located
within the partington regeneration area
and are identified for residential
development in the core strategy
so i'll talk specifically about the
whole lane site now and as i say full
planning permission is sought
for the redevelopment of this land which
part part of which was a former
caravan park the site has also protected
open space
a total of 151 residential properties
are proposed
and this will include 77 units of
affordable housing
that's 50 36 of those are affordable
rent
27 shared ownership and 14 social rented
in addition there's 15 units as private
rental and 59 units
sale on the open market
additional works at the whole lane site
include the formation of
a new internal road and layout with a
vehicular access here
and taken from hawley
a new internal road will connect with
the wider lock lane site and there will
be connectivity through
into both sites this the image on your
screen
is a cgi of the development as you would
come in from the whole lane
access landscape improvements are
proposed throughout the site
with approximately 100 new trees being
planted within the whole site alone
along with other soft landscaping works
and areas of land escaped
open space along the south east of the
site
a public right-of-way partington 4
extends through the site and is proposed
to divert this partly through a new
formalised landscape strip
and partly on a section of new estate
football
it's also proposed to look to link um
pathington 4 with a further public right
of way partington 3
and increase connectivity there the next
set of slides show
um some of the house types that will be
included in the development across both
sites
um officers have worked with the
applicant in attempt to simplify the
standard house types
um of the of the developer and
however modern methods of construction
are utilized in the build
and it was difficult to to and develop a
fully bespoke ski
so there's a couple of these on here
which show you and this one particular
is a detached dwelling
and simplified and with window apertures
and
the front door locally there is an
identified need for improvements too and
the expansion of local primary schools
which are oversubscribed
yep and has confirmed that they will
contribute the full financial
contribution
towards off-site education improvements
in addition
the applicant is also committed to the
full financial contribution towards the
carrington relief road
which is an important piece of
infrastructure which will improve
accessibility and sustainability within
partington
some harm has been identified by the
from the development and harm has been
identified to the non-designated
heritage assets of the manchester ship
canal and the kadusted viaduct
in addition there is the loss of open
space in which this site
sits on however the loss of open space
is supported by
dl3 and there is in respect to the
regeneration of partington
and in this regard the benefits are
considered to outweigh these harms
those benefits being 151 new new
dwellings which will significantly
contribute towards
the identified housing land supply
shortage approximately 50
of these will be affordable housing
we've secured full developer
contributions towards education and the
current relief road
and the development as a whole will
contribute towards the regeneration aims
of the partisan project priority
regeneration area
now we move on to the lock lane
development
as i've stated previously this site
benefits from an outline approval for up
to 550
residential units and that principle has
previously been established
the current application is the reserved
matters application for 298 residential
units
and what we're considering tonight is
the details relating to layout
scale appearance and landscaping 40 of
the new dwellings will be affordable
housing in 12 shared ownership
eight social rent and 20 affordable rent
and it should be noted that the outline
permission did not require any
affordable housing to be provided on
site
so this is above and beyond the um the
requirements of
the outline permission in addition 129
dwellings will be privately rented and
129 will be
sold on the open open market
a key component of the outline scheme
when it was considered was the delivery
of the redevelopment of the partington
shopping centre which has
obviously been carried out a number of
years ago
in addition further benefit benefits
secured outline stage
with a provision of 1.4 hectares of open
space including the neighborhood
equipped
play area and the provision of a total
of 2.4 hectares of open space is being
provided
the green loop and a contribution
towards highway and public transport
improvement is also being sought in
addition has also been secured
in addition to those sort on the whole
lane site
as with the whole lane site extensive
landscaping will will
will be carried out throughout the
development and and the
lock lane site will see 129
sorry 290 trees be planted and
a new pedestrian promenade formed along
the entire length of the site with the
canal
and the green leap green loop proposals
will extend around the proof
will extend around the periphery of
partington
new vehicle access is proposed
opposite our lady lourdes primary school
and this arrangement was approved at
outline stage
part of the approved access requires the
applicant to provide new car parking for
staff of the primary school
in order to reduce the on-street car
parking which you can see in this
photograph
installation of the new access in order
um to reduce this um an application has
been submitted and it's currently under
consideration
the next couple of slides show some
further house types and which will be
provided again across the whole of the
site this particular one is a
three-bedroomed two-story dwelling with
an integrated garage
another detached three-bedroom property
and
a further property that could either be
rendered or in brick with integral
garages and
and three stories in summary the
benefits of the lock lane development
will be
298 new dwellings which significantly
contributes
to the shortfall of in-housing land
supply that the council is experiencing
will provide 13 of the units as
affordable housing
and secure contributions towards
highways improved
environmental works and tree planting
and greater cycle and pedestrian
connectivity as well as contributing
towards the regeneration aims of the
wider partington area
on this basis both applications are
recommended for approval subject to
conditions
with the whole lane application also
subject to a section 106
agreement thank you
thank you mrs we're going to hear from
uh two speakers now the first speaker
will be speaking against the whole lane
application
uh and that is katy mcmurray miss
mcmurray
are you with us on the call i am yes
thank you i am catherine collins but i
think if you get it off my personal
email you get
worried so i do apologize okay no
problem at all
we can we can hear you well um so you'll
have three minutes
to to speak to us uh with your comments
when you get to three minutes
i'll uh just ask you to to wrap up um
so you could um if you could speak to us
no thank you thank you
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you this evening i'm representing a
number of residents of inglewood close
who will all be directly affected by
this development
all of whom have read this statement and
agreed it as well
although the residents of the road do
not object to partisan being developed
especially considering the country's
housing shortage
the way this application of 151
dwellings and the adjoining application
of 298 dwellings have been submitted
seems not to take several factors into
consideration
the existing access to the development
proposed condition
number 31 from the officers report is
welcomed however it does
not consider construction traffic prior
to occupation
also i can confirm the traffic problems
continue further than the roundabout
stated
to the next one adjacent to the retail
units at the junction of hull and what
lane
they present a significant hazard at all
times of the day currently
and both roundabouts will be accessed by
the majority of traffic using the
development sites
if the committee consents to this
development it is requested that the
wording of condition 31 is amended to
include
include the whole lock lane roundabouts
as well
uh visual immunity traffic councils own
documents require a 27 meter distance
between properties across
private gardens and 10.5 from property
boundary at the rear this is
this does not appear to have been
adhered to within the developments for
plot
300 308 312
to 319 as examples within your own
development
surely the same guidance should be
measured from existing houses backing
onto this proposed development also
several of which shaw fought at short
sorry
the following have been taken from the
developers own plans which contradicts
the officer's report paragraphs 94
97 and 98. the following relates to the
properties on inglewood close
number 37 only having a 6.5 meter rear
garden
leaves approximately 16 meters between
the properties
the rear gardens of both plots 268 269
will overlook
be overlooked by number 36 number 34 and
32
there is 25 meters between properties
although it is compliant at the 10.5
meter boundary
number 26 and 24 they only have they
have 26 meters between properties
although that is also compliant at 10.5
to the boundary
number 22 and 20 are under the 10.5
meters required to the boundary
6.9 meters from both their
conservatories used as living space and
dining rooms
and then only 21.5 meters to the
original
from their original building to the new
building numbers 18 and 16
are under the 10.5 metre boundary and
only 7.2 from both conservatories which
use this living space
noticed in the offices reports it is the
it is the impact on the existing
bungalow paragraph 100 101
as stated the report as stated in the
report that 2.5 meter heck
fencing has been requested to mitigate
the impact of privacy on the property
although this has not been followed
throughout the boundary treatment
drawings
i request that the same 2.5 meter fence
is stipulated along the boundary between
inglewood close
and plots 266 to 280.
site clearance contrary to the proposed
condition number 11 and 18
clearance works have already commenced
with trees being felt outside of the
property boundary
ms collins could you just start to wrap
up for me there please um
particularly on the land behind numbers
40 42 44 and 46
i did enclose those photos on the report
that i sent through it is requested that
prior to construction local residents
have the opportunity to comment and
discuss items
within the phasing scheme and camp
specifically construction traffic
management plan
parking vehicles and hours of
construction activity and details of
lighting as we already have
your traffic i'm sorry i know your
traffic the traffic from the
construction work that are clearing the
land parking on the road
thank you thank you miss collins
um mr evanson um
the uh mrs collins mentioned um the
roundabout at loch lane hall lane
uh and whether there should be
improvements there i don't know whether
that's something you could
advise on either either now or when
we've heard from the other speakers
yeah i i either way i can do it now or
when you've added
some comments from other speakers and if
members ask any other questions
regarding
um i don't mind either way okay
let's hear from the speakers and then we
can come back to you in case there's any
other
um sort of traffic highway matters um
we'll hear now from another speaker
speaking against the
uh the application for the land joining
the the manchester ship canal
uh and um that is uh charlotte fox miss
fox are you on the call
uh mr fox isn't on the call uh she's
requested that her statement be read out
and i will do that chairman
okay thank you miss curly curley
i'm writing this statement as a local of
the area arguing against the planning
application adjoining
both lock lane and thermal road there
are several reasons to why the
construction work for this application
should not be approved
many of which i will briefly discuss
below
firstly pollution regarding the
pollution levels
plans to add 298 dwellings into the area
of partington
will raise carbon dioxide emissions
considerably
with transportation and construction
work being the two main contributing
factors to air pollution
it is without a doubt this application
is a cause for environmental concern
with this in mind increasing air
pollution will not only impose a risk to
the environmental features of partington
but will also put the health and
well-being of locals in question
this alone goes to show one reason of
many to why this development will do
more harm than good
how can an increase in carbon dioxide
emissions be a benefit to this area
loss of privacy secondly i would like to
raise the issue which has been highly
discussed by locals of block lane
the loss of privacy personally having
lived on loch lane for over 30 years
the concept of there being housing built
behind my own home so close to our back
garden is shocking
the layout of housing being so close to
current locals living here is not only
unfair
but it opposes risk to our privacy due
to other residents of this proposed
build
overlooking our own although we
understand developments occur from time
to time
the privacy of lane structure was a
contributing factor to why many of us
moved here
therefore developing houses on land so
close to our own is not something we
thought would occur
especially as the land behind our homes
is green field
we believe such a build should have
aimed to be located onto brownfield land
which would also have decreased
environmental destruction
and conservation enhanced wildlife
relating to the conservation of nature
and wildlife
there are mass concerns regarding the
impact this plan has and will continue
to have on nature if planning goes ahead
as stated i have lived on this road the
majority of my life and i am beyond
appalled at the way decades of precious
wildlife has been destroyed because of
this planning application
it really is a shame to see more
valuable nature ripped apart for the
benefit of the business's finances
many years i have not only taken care of
the wildlife living behind my home
but i have also enjoyed regular walks
nearby the canal with my family and
friends
it is beyond a shame to see such
beautiful wildlife be ripped from their
habitats and they should be treated so
disgracefully
now if you still do not believe this
planning application of poses risks to
the nature and wildlife of partington
then come and take a look for yourself
come and see what this plan has already
done to some of manchester's greatest
natural habitats and wildlife
noise pollution i am quite astounded by
the fact that a recent noise assessment
has taken place and resulted
in noise not being needed for
consideration regarding this build
yet while writing this i am currently
sat in my living room listening to
constant noise coming from the
deforestation taking place right behind
our back
garden now how accurate must the 3d
noise model be
if clearly noise has already impacted
myself my children and my neighbors
to conclude i completely disagree with
the planning application to build on the
land
nearby loch lane as stated this judgment
is based on the impact of pollution
loss of privacy harm to wildlife and
noise pollution which will occur
in addition i just want to ask yourself
this question if the planning
application was destined for success
and the benefit of locals how come there
are so many reasons to object
when did wealth become more important
than welfare if you take anything from
my argument today
let this be this this planning
application has and will continue to
cause extreme harm to the wildlife and
natural environment within partisan
harm which is both irreversible and a
national and global concern
why not choose to save our environment
while you have the chance
thank you for listening i hope my
concerns along with others can be heard
i think it seems many times the planning
committee ignores the needs of locals
and prioritizes other aspects like
financial gain
so please bear these reasons stated by
locals in mind when deciding whether or
not to continue this planning
application
the local myself i feel we know what is
best for the area we have grown up and
lived in
so do not ignore these serious concerns
thank you
thank you miss curley um we'll hear from
a speaker
in favor of of both applications now and
that's mr pemberton mr pemberton
are you on the call i am yes thank you
john
thank you mr pemberton um because you're
speaking to both applications
uh you'll have uh six minutes to speak
to us so
uh and i'll i'll just ask you to wrap up
if you if you reach to six minutes
um so if you could um address your
comments to us now would be grateful
thank you
yes thank you i'm addressing you today
in respect of the two applications for a
total of 449 dwellings
on land at loch lane and hall lane in
partington
the site is contiguous and has been
planned as a sinkhole
single entity outline planning
commission for the development of up to
550 dwellings was originally granted on
the lock lane site
in june 2010 and the permission extended
in september 2019
the principle of residential development
at loch lane has therefore been
established
irrespective of this parting remains a
priority regeneration area for the
council
and planning policy supports the
delivery of new residential development
app lock lane approval is sought for the
details of appearance layout
scale and landscaping for the direction
of 298 dwellings
pursuant to the outline permission this
includes the delivery of 40
affordable homes which is 13 at hall
lane
a full application seeks permission for
a further 151 dwellings
this includes the delivery of 77
affordable homes
equating to 51 of the overall provision
an additional access onto hall lane will
provide a loop through the site
a fact welcomed by your highway officers
countryside have submitted a separate
application for the improvement of the
parking at the primary school opposite
the site entrance
this has been designed in collaboration
with the school and has currently been
considered
in total 449 dwellings are proposed
including a mix of two three and four
bedroom homes
ensuring that local needs for both
smaller and larger family homes are
being met
117 affordable homes at 26
is significantly more than the policy
requirement of 10
in good market conditions these
affordable homes are 10-year blind and
include a mix of shared ownership
affordable rent and social rent tenures
this represents a considerable
contribution to meeting affordable
housing needs
detailed analysis of the design and
character of the area has been
undertaken to inform the scheme the
design of the house types has evolved
during the consideration of the
applications they fully complement the
character of the surrounding area
and have the support of your officers
the layouts have responded to existing
homes adjoining the site
with interfaces distances meeting the
council standards
the scheme will provide 2.4 hectares of
public open space
this will be split into five separate
areas incorporating
play facilities and a green loop the
scheme
also provides extensive landscaping
making the proposals an attractive place
to live
this includes a boulevard of trees along
the main roads within the site
and significant landscape improvements
along the ship canal
it will also incorporate and improve
public rights of way which exist within
and
adjacent to the site the combined
development is significantly below the
550 dwellings taken as a long-standing
commitment by the council
the scheme before you will deliver
around 100 units less
the reduced number of properties has
been caused by
two main reasons the need to accommodate
additional flood storage
and the absence of high-density
apartments from the scheme
the scheme has however significant
viability issues and requires grant
funding to deliver the affordable
housing the applicants have reluctantly
agreed to the financial contributions
towards the carrington relief road from
the hall
lane site in order to avoid further
delays in progressing this scheme
great places as the registered provider
for the affordable homes and sigma for
the private rented
housing need to make a start on site
this financial year to secure
home homes england funding any delay to
the scheme
puts this funding at risk and thus the
delivery of affordable homes
on both schemes in addition to the
carrington relief road contributions
the applicant has also agreed to the
further the full education contribution
of 451 000 pounds
these contributions are made even though
viability matters have not been
concluded
overall the layout of the development
accords with the broad principles
established by the extant outline plan
commission it fully complies with the
policies of the development plan and
national planning policy
no significant adverse impacts have been
identified for either scheme
they represent a high quality
development within a priority
area for regeneration countryside has a
proven track record of delivering homes
in the northwest
and specializes in building communities
the approval of these applications will
make a significant contribution to
trafford's housing land supply
in the absence of a five-year supply it
will provide much-needed
market and affordable housing to meet
identified needs
while bringing economic environment
environmental and social benefits
we fully endorse your office's
recommendation to approve these
applications and ask for your support
thank you thank you mr pemberton
um mr everson could we come back to you
now for the
advice on the lock lane hall lane
roundabout
please indeed yeah um yeah we did um
consider the the roundabout in question
but as mentioned um a few times tonight
the the site itself as permission for
some 550 houses
all be the full application is
additional land
but the the number which we are
considering this evening and we've
considered them
together as well as they are being heard
tonight
the the development itself already got
planning
outline planning permission and whilst
there's some changes to
the distribution of the traffic with the
introduction of the whole lane access
the impact on the roundabout which has
been raised the whole lane lock lane
roundabout
isn't significant whereby we could
justify any improvements
over and above the the outline
permission which was granted
so therefore we didn't feel justified in
requiring
um any improvements and so we we've
we've considered it in the in the realm
yes there's a potential issue with
regards to
could they build out fully the 550
dwellings on the
site which has got outlined planning
permission but we believe that's
unlikely given the flood issues on the
remaining parts of the land
so we believe that the two developments
combined
is below the outline and we didn't feel
we could justify any improvements at
that junction
okay thank you very much that's that's
really helpful uh
councillor jerome i think you had a
question
quick question for sarah lowe's i think
you mentioned in the
um in your presentation the landscaping
plan
and i think you had a fixed number of
trees i just noticed in the uh
officer's report it i think it does
does say that um the master plan does
detail individual trees across the side
but as
no stated breakdown of species numbers
yet provided
i just wondered if that changed and you
had a kind of definitive number of the
trees they were
supplying yes yes we do have a
definitive number of trees now
and that's been an update from the um
the
report and so 390 trees across both
sites
100 on the whole lane site and 290 on
the lock lane site
do you have a breakdown of which trees
and which numbers or is it
not not of species um
i'm thinking of the larger yolk trees
and the
yes no we don't have details of species
yes yes there are um comprehensive
landscaping
um conditions on the um the
the scheme which would enable us to get
the breakdown of species
but i think the report if i'm correct
does um reference the amount and size
and so the different type the the
different types you know the street
trees the garden trees
and it breaks that down into the numbers
that's somewhere in the
report i can find out what paragraphs
that is for you just bear with me a
second
unless you want to answer in the chat
yeah okay yeah yeah
thank you good job thank you mrs um
just looking for members wishing to
speak now in relation to both
applications so um
council accordingly thanks jeff
um i'm happy to propose both
applications i think they're good
proposals they've been in the um
development for a long long time
probably as long as i've been a
counselor to be honest
um
they're not perfect by any means but i i
do support
um it's not going to alter my view of
this but i do think it's regretful that
all the focus in sort of
traffic alleviation is on the carrington
relief road
when you have a viaduct immediately
above
this development that um
i think it's hamilton davis have been
looking to develop for
connectivity for a long time and it's
still considered viable by
transport for greater manchester but we
don't seem to do anything
about it the the particularly with these
two
proposals their proximity to worlham
station just across the canal
it's this incredible asset to squander
that we don't do anything about we talk
about getting people onto the road
but i looked at the timetables for um
lenham station and it's
15 minutes to manchester the center of
manchester
even slower to warrington even faster to
swat warrington
and it does occur to me that one of
these days people are going to look back
and think why did we never
develop a link over to the other side
for people to
walk or use but like light transit
transit to
but that is an issue for another day
it's not appropriate to this
i just couldn't resist be being under
that viaduct these two applications i do
support them
um and um i'm happy to listen to other
people but
at the extent i i'm happy to propose
thank you
thank you council of the corner it's a
it's a good point well made i think
about about the viaduct and and having
another crossing across the um
across the ship canal which is you know
which is solely needed
um cancer carer you wanted to speak
uh thank you chairman um there are so
many plans at the minute for partings in
the warburton site these two
sites carrington included i'm just going
to
talk about why i always talk about his
education provision
and reading the reports the first report
for the whole lane site states 451 000
which is
really welcome but then in the report
for the second site the larger site it
actually says that
um but it's disappointing that there is
no
uh developer funding for that part of
the site it does really concern me you
know
451 000 spread over three primary
schools
the secondary school probably can uh
take some children in but those three
primary schools are really going to
struggle
what can that provide is that enough for
the
amount of houses that are being built
just over those two sides
we do need people watching this tonight
in partington and carrington do need to
know
what this money can be how this money is
going to be spent what it's going to be
spent on is it enough
to provide the education places that
their children who because they already
live there
are now going to be competing for we
just need some transparency and clarity
over
education funding for this part of the
borough with the amount of houses i'm a
big
massive supporter of this developed
these developments being built
and as i say every single time i'm a
partington boy i'm so proud of it
this will help with this relief road you
know we need more houses it's a great
place to live
like we've just been speaking about
maybe this development of connecting
over the water to
uh the railway line fantastic but
these people need to know can their kids
get in a place in education
is this money enough if it isn't why
isn't it not enough
why are we even considering the second
application going through
if there's not going to be enough cash
there thank you chairman
well thank you councillor carey um miss
coley one of you could just
just address that point councillor carey
makes so my understanding on the second
application is that
we're approving reserve matters so um
you know in a sense that the the chance
has gone to get a contribution from that
application towards
education provision and i think it
addresses you know the the
contribution was she cured was towards
the um was towards the the shopping
center
which is which has been done um is
is that right yes that that that's
correct
and when the outline permission was
considered
and the benefits of the re and
development of the shopping center
and the other benefits that it was
providing and there was viability issues
wider on the site and that there wasn't
there wasn't an opportunity to secure
education contributions at that time
and because we're only considering the
reserve matters at this stage which is
just the detail we aren't able to rev
unfortunately we're unable to revisit
the education contributions for the lock
lane scheme
thank you mrs um councillor procter you
wanted to speak
yeah thanks chair i mean there is a
there's an awful lot to commend this
this well these both these applications
um obviously the main one is it
contributes to the
housing supply which is a massive issue
in trafford
and you know that will will massively
contribute to that
i think it's quite a good a good mix and
range of properties
and the affordable percentages
is to be commended really and it's it's
much higher than
it needed to be and i think i'm not
particularly happy with the the social
run numbers ever
for working out this only total of 22
which for this
number of units is is quite low
and disappointing really but i suppose
that's
that's the best we're going to get and i
can understand a lot of the
sort of local residents concerns about
the developments because it's going to
change partington
completely it's going to be a completely
different place than it is already
so that vast numbers of people coming in
is going to massively change the
whole nature of the area and i wonder
how many of those people actually be
you know local local partington people
but anyway that's a that's a separate
matter
um my major concern
lies around the the level of congestion
obviously we've got the the relief road
and the level of parking parking
facilities
spaces is quite good um so i think pot
parking is
not much of an issue but we're going to
get
large numbers of cars let's be honest
in in these new developments and is the
relief road and the what's been proposed
going to be sufficient to satisfy that
i'm not so sure
i i do have some cons concerns about
that particularly
when you take into account the poor
level of public transport
and public provision in partington i
know there's some money going into that
but um i do worry that
all these cars um are going to have a
major impact on the
congestion levels and impact on not only
the
the new people moving in but the the
partington residents themselves
i know highways have looked to this and
said that they think there's
gonna be no major issues i'm i'm not
sure it just does really worry me
so i think overall i you know will be
voting for the epic in favor of the
applications
but i do have concerns about the
congestion
traffic congestion levels going forward
so i'd be really
happy to hear a bit more about that and
what other members have to say
on on that particular issue thank you
chair
thank you councillor procter um miss
eliza do you want to come back on
something that
that councilor proctor said
sorry no that comment was in relation to
m councillor
sorry right thank you yeah i've just
sorry i've just seen the message um
we've got uh counselor morgan you wanted
to
sorry i beg your pardon councillor
jerome you wanted to to speak on the on
the application as well
a good application i mean the the
affordable housing um
does look pretty good to me i mean and
also the
the amount of family homes um which is
a really good percentage of family homes
free bed plus um so i think that that
will contribute to kind of traffic's
overall housing need
and i'm happy with the design of the
houses as well i think the design
is generally good and i think officers
have done a good job on that
um i also was quite pleased with the
energy efficiency
i like the um the positive input
ventilation system
i think that's welcome i mean if if you
don't know it pulls
and filters fresh air into the house
while removing stale air
this removes polluted air in in the
house creating a healthier indoor
environment which is a very good thing
it's not quite the mechanical
ventilation heat recovery system used
in passive house design which also
requires a tight insulation
but it is welcome um but i thought it
was a real shame
that the developer is using gas boilers
and when they could be moving away from
fossil fuels
and if you do look at the mppf 0.151 b
it says consider identifying suitable
areas for renewable and low carbon
energy sources
and supporting infrastructure where this
would help secure their development
and i do think the location of this
development in terms of solar panels
um wind uh generation um
that we we shouldn't be looking at gas
boilers um especially with our climate
emergency so
i'm it's a bit of a shame that uh
officers didn't do more maybe to
persuade the developer to
to look at kind of a you know different
type of
energy for the houses but the positive
input ventilation system really is
welcome because they do improve air
quality within houses
and improve people's health so i'm
pleased about that
i also like the landscaping
topographical plan
um it's really welcome that they're
putting in silver birch black cherry
copper beach and costa roque
as part of the landscaping scheme i
think that's a really really good
mix of trees and native trees and also
the landscaping
um with the wildflower area is also
welcomed
and and they i think they're going to be
using emma's gate seeds general
purpose wildflower mix and if you look
at that mix it's got things like yarrow
yellow rattle among others a really good
native mix of of world flower so i hope
mrs lowe's is right and they are
actually committing to using that
those seed sources and those trees
because uh
i think they will be a good feature in
this housing development and one i think
it's a good one
but what does really um disappoint me
about the
ecology i like the ecology on the site
as i've just said with the landscaping
but as the gm eu does point out in the
office's report 188 um it does
recommend further areas of semi-natural
green spaces provided
within the application boundary or a
contribution
made off-site habitat and green space
provision
and because we're giving a developer
contribution so highly
to uh the um the link road i don't call
it a relief road i don't think it is
i think it's a link road um and
because we're giving so much money to
that we're not um contributing to
ecology offsite and that does worry me
because
we're going to see application after
application in parkington and carrington
where we're not committing money to the
ecology of the area
and i think um also the travel plan for
this application
um you know public transport as
councillor procter pointed out
is is pretty woeful and needs a large
amount of
in investment so i think that's another
problem
but i did see in the um the additional
information report that the public
right-of-way
situation is looking more positive um
but on conclusion i think i'm um
inclined
to um go with officer recommendation
um and support this but i do have
concerns
as i said about the off-site ecology
which is not being
improved and the public transport
but i do like some of the energy
efficiency measures but i think it could
be better especially on the get the gas
boilers
thank you chair
thank you councillor jerome uh
councillor morgan you wanted to speak
thank you chair and i'm going to keep
this really really brief because we've
got a lot to get through and i think
anything i've said will be repeated um
by
other previous members i think generally
a pretty exciting
um development um um we need the more
more houses um and i think i mean look
through the scheme i think there's a
real lot of positives
as council accordingly said it isn't
perfect i do agree with him in terms of
the fact that uh if we had a very short
transport link um just over the uh over
the um the border
um really does make sense and why we
aren't doing these sort of things i
really don't know especially as
good public transport is a real um thing
that attracts people
um at the one point i really want to
rate and i do
share council process points about
transport and road congestion but
is what council care he said this is
i've only been on this commit i've been
a counselor for less than two years
and that this is probably the third or
fourth big development that we are
building in partington and yet again
every single time this comes up
about school provision um and we really
really do need to
actually properly address this not just
kind of
say well we need the houses and um
therefore
we've got to get it through this is a
real issue and you know i'm sure all the
members have these in terms of really
popular schools and
problems in terms of getting kids into
school places and i really really do
need to start
seriously addressing the the school
shortage in primary education
in um trafford there are particular year
groups which is really causing problems
um and it's it is just going to be a
real
real disaster for for families if we
don't really seriously address it but
having said that just come back to what
i was like i will be supporting this um
tonight
um thank you chad thank you council
morgan
um councillor rigby i i know you want to
to speak uh
i've seen a message i'm just sort of
taking speakers in the order that they
come up in the chat so i think uh
council acton uh you had a question i
think if i could come to you know
yes yes thank you ben um
i think there is a a a lot uh
and people have uh said this a lot of
positives in the development
and i am supportive of it i think it
will help in terms of
significantly help with the regeneration
of partington
the question is around
gm police and their comments
designed for security
they have no objection in principle
subject to condition requiring the
development to reflect
the physical security specifications set
out in the
crime impact statements um
and i just wonder whether that has
actually been included in the report i
couldn't see it or i might have
uh missed it but i would hope that we
would you know
agree with the specifications that
they've set
out and that's on both reports
thank you councilloraton miss those is
that something you could help us with
whether that's
in the conditions yes i believe it to be
i'm just looking through the conditions
now to find the numbers if you just bear
with me a second
fine we can we can come back to that uh
miss those um
councillor rigby uh you wanted to speak
on the applications
yes thanks very much um i'm sorry
i'm going to have to repeat something
which um council morgan and carey
have brought up um i know i brought up
education previously
i don't want to sound like an old
graphone record
but we're not getting any answers as
so i'd really this into criticism it's
more for clarity
as council that carried allude to um
the application relating to school
places
does mention the shortage quite clearly
of primary school places in partington
um you know 449
additional families is going to attract
an awful lot of children i know the
report states
in the developer is going to
contribution of 450
50 747
have been calculated however it
it would appear that the local
the primary schools themselves have not
been
consulted to determine
if there is scope at these schools to
our places
which you know as the report says there
are four schools important and i well
know that
one secondary and three primary the
primary does have
capacity and ample capacity but the
three primary schools don't
the schools are either academy
or voluntary aided
and i can't find any evidence
that the schools have been contacted
which i thought was important
you know it's disappointing um
as in this report you know it's a good
report it's a great report we receive
a good deal of information on
infrastructure proposed highways
landscaping ecology out
biodiversity all this will come we're
given assurances
in order that we can make a decision or
reach a decision
but little detail is included to ensure
ourselves as members there will be
sufficient school places
for families you know not just
families moving into the area but
existing families
i say it's disappointing because i'm
sure members know
it's the council's duty to ensure that
children
living in our borough are offered a
school place
it's not the school's responsibility
it's not the developers responsibility
it's the local authorities
responsibility throughout the country
to provide school places for the
children living in their borough
um so
is there the ability
for these schools to expand can they
build is there the funding to it
that will make this possible and the
bottom line is
shouldn't there be a more depth in-depth
report
to say that in increasing the school
sizes
is feasible it's a possibility wouldn't
it be embarrassing
if a school puts an application
to increase in size then we refused it
on planning grounds you know this is the
practicalities
of this you know i'm not trying to be
awkward i'm not trying to be nitpicky
but i think with it um certainly a
development of this size
bringing 449 children
which will need places at years one to
eleven
years one to eleven it's not just a year
entry one or not just a year entry seven
in secondary schools it's a year
every year we'll have to find way now
every year's
full we've been told this so it's
it's a real problem because a community
relies on its schools
show me a successful community and i'll
show you a successful school
we all know that as councillors
but parents become very dissatisfied
they become angry
they become disillusioned when they
cannot get this place
at a local school for their children and
i can't see any evidence
i can really evidence that sufficient
um inquiries and consultation
has taken place that assures us
that that's going to happen i'm sorry
it's lame at the point if you don't mind
but but i think it's a real issue which
should be considered now and in the
future thank you very much indeed for
the town chairman
thank you councillor uh miss those are
miss coley is there
anything more you'd want to say on that
i know we've sort of answered the point
about the
the contribution um towards education i
think
councillor rigby's wanting more than
that i suppose about how that
provision's going to
going to appear is is that something we
need to
address tonight in this committee
i don't think it is i think i think just
to just to clarify we've
we've sought the full contribution that
we can from the whole lane application
and we cannot secure any further
contribution on the lock lane
and the details in how um that
is applied and how we develop those
schemes
going forward with education i think is
a different conversation for
a different point in time and we do
consult with education and education
give us very detailed comments in terms
of which schools can potentially expand
how they could expand
and and where the places are needed so
that does obviously
um link back to where we we get the
contributions and how we take those
thank forward mister was that that's
helpful so yeah i think i think the
position is we
we've secured a contribution on the um
on the full application uh which is
detailed we can't go back and and
revisit those matters already approved
on the
application um and and how those monies
are spent and how the provision appears
is is is not is not a decision uh it's
not a decision for us
um councillor ministry wanted to speak
and i think after council of minnesota
i'll see if anyone wants to move the
motion to um to vote to approve the
applications
uh council minister yeah thank you i
don't want to repeat
what a lot of people said um i've got a
few
concerns but uh i think it's been
summarized by a lot of lots of the other
comments
and the school thing is one that does
concern me the most um i understand that
we can't ask for contributions on one of
the schemes
um because it's already been gone and we
have on the other and we've got the full
contributions we can't go any further
with that
um the i just wonder whether in future
we can have
um as like effectively council rugby's
uh pointed out in the report
we can have that um those conversations
that have been
have had been had with the education
department about
schools potentially expanding and
therefore how much that would cost to
expand those schools
where those conversations can be um
recorded in the report so that we can
see that when we when we're approving
these these decisions um
then that would be really helpful uh
thank you
thanks thank you councilman um miss
curley i think he wanted to
uh answer ans question yes if i could
the difficulty we have here is is
separating out what a planning matters
for a planning report and what are
matters for the uh
council's education authority with its
school place planning
now there is a already a reporting
mechanism for those kind of
conversations about which schools should
be expanded what funding is available
um how that might happen and and where
and that reporting is is
through the exec member for for uh
education and entered in into the
executive
it would not be appropriate to include
that information in the planning
application because it would go beyond
the scope of of that planning
application we consult our education
colleagues
they tell us whether there is a shortage
of school places in the area they tell
us what contribution
they would want to seek um sometimes
they are able to identify as a specific
scheme it would go for and this goes for
all applications not not just this one
and not not just
the one in partington going further than
that and having a discussion about what
what particular
uh school place options are being
considered is just beyond the remit of
this committee and beyond the remit of
the planning applications and the
discussion thank you chairman
uh thank you miss khalia that's that's
great that answered that answer my
question thank you
thank you mr coley um i think we've had
a i think we had a lot of contributions
um a lot a lot of um a decent debate
there about about the issues
um council accordingly i think moved
that we
um moved the motion that we accept the
the recommendation of the offices on on
both of the applications
i don't think anyone has has uh
suggested a motion to to reject
either recommendation um is anyone
willing to second
council recording this okay i'll second
that yeah
thank you councillor so it's been moving
seconded we accept officer
recommendation in relation to both
applications
so we'll move to the votes now and we'll
vote on on each application separately
so
um first of all we'll vote on the
application for the land
off whole lane which is the application
for full planning permission
that's the one that starts on page 33
um so the officer recommendation is
minded to grant subject
to the to the legal agreement um so i'll
go through the names of counselors in in
the order that
they come up on my uh on my screen
so first of all uh councillor rigby
support the officer's recommendation
chair
thank you councillor uh councillor
procter support officer recommendation
to grant
thank you councillor proctor uh
councillor acton
all the recommendations chair
thank you councillor acton uh councillor
akanola
i support the recommendation
thank you councillor canola uh
councillor jerome
don't you sorry was that support can you
say jerome
yes i support the recommendation thank
you councillor jerome uh councillor
morgan
support officer recommendations jeff
thank you council morgan
uh councillor dr barclay a support
officer recommendation to grind
thank you councillor barclay uh
councilmembers
and i support support the officer's
recommendation to grant thank you
thank you councilman councillor
accordingly support officer's
recommendation to grant
chair thank you councillor accordingly
uh councillor carey thank you chairman i
support the officer's recommendation
thank you council carey um i'll be
supporting the recommendation as well
i don't think i forgot anyone um please
show it up if i have admitted anyone
so i think that's uh unanimously uh in
favor of
um officer recommendation on the first
application
if we go now to the second application
which is the um
the application for the the land
adjacent to the monster ship canal
starts on page 106 of the bundle uh
and uh the officer recommendation here
is to
grant the application so i will uh
go through members in the in the same
order as as first time round if i could
so
um councillor rigby on the on the second
application here would you like to
vote yes chairman i support the
officer's recommendation
thank you councillor uh councillor
proctor
came to the props are you still in the
car
sorry i had problems support officer
recommendation to grant
thank you councillor procter councillor
acton what the recommendations
joe thank you council acton uh
councillor akinola
brought the recommendation to grant
thank you councilman
uh councilman jerome
thank you councillor jerome uh
councillor morgan
support officer recommendation to grant
chair thank you councillor morgan
uh councillor dr barclay
sorry i support the office of
recommendation to grant thank you
council dr barclay uh councillor minis
i support the officer's recommendation
to grant thank you
thank you councilman council accordingly
support officer's recommendation to
grant you
thank you councillor councillor carey
thank you chairman i support the
officer's recommendation
thank you councillor and i will also be
uh supporting the recommendation
so again that's uh unanimous on on that
application to
approve the office of recommendation to
grant
so i think that brings us to the end of
those two
items for uh partington i wonder if we
could get
i don't know if councillor williams has
remained on the call or whether we need
to
message him to rejoin us with the next
item
don't worry about that thanks love to
you um
so we're now turned to 64-66 told the
road which is on page 117
of the committee report and the
application is going to be introduced by
mr pearson
yes thank you chairman just bear with me
while i
try and share my screen can everybody
see uh
see the screen now
i think it's uh okay this is a scheme
for
149 residential apartments in
two apartment buildings and the
retention
of a victorian villa as an office you
can see
the site here just off tolbert road this
is oakland house the really tall
long office building british gas
building here
and the town halls just off the back
down in this corner here
number 64 uh tolbert road
this one here is a victorian villa we
consider it to be a non-designated
heritage asset
the poor quality extensions and
outbuildings at the back will
will be demolished and 66 talbot road
and botanical house
both former offices that will be
demolished to accommodate
the development some photographs of the
existing buildings there you can see the
villa on the right and the
existing office buildings on the left
uh next slide is site plan and there are
two
blocks of developments there's a six
storey residential apartment block
proposed
on the front of the site here sitting
next to the victorian villa
and then we've got the uh a further
dot b uh residential apartment block at
the back of the site
and that ranges in height from 13
stories
at its closest point to oakland house
and drops down to 11 stories on the
right hand side
of you as you look to on screen
block a is located to the front of the
side
it's six stories as i mentioned uh 33
units in this
twelve or one bed seventeen to two bed
and four or two bed
duplex apartments on the ground or
fronting toilet road over here
bulges that's not an easy drawing to to
see on screen
side elevation just below it and
the next slide shows you the rear
elevation um
and the main ideal election
block b the the tallest building uh
would accommodate 116 dwellings
65 one bed 48 two bed and
three three bed apartments there's
basement car parking for 17 vehicles
37 units within block b have a private
terrorist and balcony space
these are generally recessed and they
add interest to the appearance of the
building
in their opinion uh there you see the
the front elevation of it that's
the one that faces the uh landscaped
courtyard between the two boxed
there you see the rear elevation which
will look over
white city retail park
and then the two side elevations
slide there indicates the landscape
strategy
um and you can see at the front of the
site here the
ground floor duplex units in um
in the six story building will have
their own access ways and
and front gardens um
in between we've we've got a communal
residence garden here
and along here the ground floor units
um in this rear block also have some
private garden space here
and then on the roof there's also
an end up both an indoor and an outdoor
communal area for
residents
next slide shows you the street scene
that's um
sort of heading uh east up into to
manchester
looking down towards the town hall
there's oakland house
uh the original building um you can see
the villa
hiding amongst the trees here those
trees do exist by the way that's not
artistic license
um the six story uh building here and
then obviously the taller block
at the back
okay um the design is obviously
contemporary um it does take design cues
from number 64 tolbert road
through the interpretation of design
features such as chamfered corners and
brickwork detailing
let's bring the next slide up now
there's one of the the cgi's
taken from just across the other side of
the talbot road
a bit about the scheme that the
principle of developments of residential
development on bret on this brownfield
site
is considered to be acceptable and will
obviously contribute towards the
council's five-year housing land supply
scale and massing of the scheme is
considered to be
appropriate to the site uh in its
context in in the view of offices
um as you can see the development steps
down in height from this
back from the left hand side here at 13
stories down to
11 stories here and as i mentioned the
six story block at the front it's
considered that the design is
is high quality the use of red brick
projecting bays
you can see here on both buildings
terraces
up here at the higher levels um
brickwork detailing is a lot of
brickwork detailing on on the proposal
uh along with well designed fedestration
details
they all we think uh add interest and
should successfully break up the facades
of the
of the proposed development the scheme
provides 33
affordable units all shared ownership
which represents a 22 provision
now that also represents a change you
will have noticed to the original
officer report which detailed on
paragraph six of the edition information
report
and whilst it's not com policy compliant
in in the sense that
there are no affordable rented units
mostly
officers think that due to the
considerable uplift in the overall
affordable housing provision um
which would have only been 10 previously
we think that
is an acceptable uh offer and
represents a betterment on the on the
original policy compliant 10 offer
it's considered that the scheme wells
high density represents sufficient use
of
a brownfield site provide a mix of
communal and private immunity space for
residents as i've already mentioned
whilst a small number of the units don't
fully comply with the nationally
described space ban
standards some units do not fulfill we
can play recommended guidelines in terms
of amenity
emails nevertheless considered to be
acceptable given its context
this game incorporates 17 parking spaces
and 156 secure
cycle parking spaces which we think in
this location
is acceptable in terms of contributions
the development provides a
policy compliance suite of contributions
towards affordable housing
full education contribution towards the
commission of primary and secondary
school places
spatial green infrastructure and outdoor
sports provision
in carrying out the weighted balancing
exercise of paragraph 11 in the mppf
it's considered that the benefits of the
scheme significantly outweigh the
adverse impacts
and so it's recommended for approval
subject to a section 106 application
and there's just a couple um of
additional slides there that shows the
internal
uh internal
thank you mr pearson and there's one
speaker to this application
um quantum valley mr valadili
on call hi i'm sure yeah and you'll have
three minutes to speak and if you do run
over that time i'll just politely
request that you wrap up your rematch
thank you
thank you chair good evening members my
name is conor valdez from madison young
i'm the planning agent for the
application
as members will be aware this highly
sustainable brownfield site
is identified as a key opportunity for
residential redevelopment
in the draft civic quarter area action
plan
also referred to as aap this document is
getting increasing weight
and planning decisions as it progresses
to formal examination
the principle of development fully
accords with the development plan and
the emerging aap
which identifies the site within the
eastern neighborhood
the council's objective for the eastern
neighborhood is for high quality
residential let development
and this game delivers that in tandem
with the refurbishment of the victorian
villa
a key heritage benefit the proposals
also occurred
with the aap's broader objectives
including specific guidance for this
area
in terms of building heights and
achieving a high quality of design
the scheme will deliver high levels of
energy efficiency and carbon emission
reductions
in lime accounts of policy sustainable
drainage techniques
and seeks to capitalize on the site's
excellent accessibility credentials
with plenty full cycle parking this game
will capture a number of important
benefits
not least the inclusion of 22 on-site
affordable housing as you've heard
over double the 10 policy requirements
for this area
as well as significantly improving the
appearance of the local area
in addition to a valuable contribution
to the borough's housing supply
if members grant approval the
application will also guarantee
over four hundred thousand pounds
towards local education
and over two hundred thousand pounds
towards great infrastructure and outdoor
sports
members just in terms of delivery i'd
like to note that the applicant
investor property group is an
award-winning developer based in
manchester
so is local and has an excellent track
record of delivering large-scale schemes
across the uk
and they have a primary focus of adding
social value through urban regeneration
invest rc's trafford is a key location
for future investment
and wishes to stress that it supports
the council on its wider aims and
objectives to deliver regeneration
and to raise living standards needless
to say
they are extremely keen to get on and
deliver the site as soon as possible
in summary members the application is
wholly acceptable in planning terms as
you've heard from officers
with a considerable set of benefits and
importantly
there are no technical objections
members again this will provide a
further shot in the arm along with the
recent approval of
the regeneration of the former kellogg
site and further stimulate regeneration
in this part of trafford and deliver a
significant number of high-quality new
homes on brownfield land
i would like to thank your officers for
their hard work in working with the
applicant
and ourselves as planning agents in
achieving this very high quality scheme
which we believe will set a benchmark
for design more generally within this
part of the bureau
we respectfully request you to grant
planning permission in line with
officer's recommendation
thank you for your time
thank you mr villally and council
accordingly i think you've indicated
that you'd like to speak
sorry about that yeah yeah i'm happy to
propose i think it's a good uh
i think it's a good scheme uh i'm not
entirely comfortable with the uh space
standards but
um actually it's quite an attractive one
and my
main calculation is
is really squeezing out the office to uh
resi um
um conversions that have been taking the
place in that area
i mean this is light years ahead of
those and
i think in common with the one uh up at
um seymour grove i think i think that
this is a really
attractive development so fully support
um happy to propose um thank you thank
you
council recording the council of akanova
um i welcome the use of um brown site
and um it is better accommodation than a
lot that have been done around there
recently on seymour grove
and on talbot road where they've
converted offices
and i am disappointed that there is an
although i welcome the fact that there's
22 percent affordable
homes and but i'm not happy about the
fact that there isn't any social rented
housing
because there is a desperate need in old
trafford for that so i'm a bit
disappointed
and i'm also concerned about there only
being 17 car parking spaces
i know it'd love to discourage car use
but i don't think it necessarily will
that there isn't car parking space make
people use their bikes
even though there's so many bikes
parking spaces so i'm a bit concerned
about
um the over spill of parking and going
further up to
seymour grove because there isn't any
parking there and back onto the estates
around there and but other than that um
we need housing um up here i just wish
there was more
affordable and social thank you
councillor and counselor minis
uh thank you chair um i've got so i'm
really i like like the fact that it's a
brownfield site i've got a question
though
um that is about the heights of the two
buildings the two
sets of buildings are they um similar to
what the buildings
that are gonna get demolished are um
or are they any higher that's that's
just all my question is thank you
um no um as i've indicated the heights
are
significantly different to the existing
buildings on site
the building at the back of the site
rises to 13 stories
i mean it's massively higher than the
existing buildings
um but because because uh
it's it's next to our column house and
and because we
feel it conforms with the emerging
master plan
um the aap as pointed out
we feel this area is one that can
accommodate tall buildings
uh and particularly on this this in this
particular part of tolbert road i mean
it is at a point
uh which the aap identifies where we're
looking to to
to drop heights as it gets as you as you
as you get closer to the the set of
victorian villains that you see at that
top end of toronto road
but i mean to once you've questioned the
nutshell you know
they're very different yeah it's the
the shorter one um how much higher is it
than the building it's going to march
and i realize a really tall one is very
very tall
um it's the it's the shorter one that
i'm just how much taller is it sorry
um just bear with me just let me double
check the height of the um
yeah the one that's closer to the site i
think three
three stories um and the proposed
building is
is six stories um at the front of the
site
thank you very much thank you welcome
and councillor dr barkley thank you
chairman uh yeah i really like the
scheme it's kind of grown on me the more
i've learnt about it and i've seen it
i think it's a really nice scheme i
think it's great that it's replacing
uh office space which um is a good use
um
of it i also really really like the
design i think the brick works nice and
the recessing for the run
for the balconies is good it's a really
really lovely um
development and also really pleased that
obviously
it's so close to the metrolink so it's
kind of sustainable in terms of travel
travel links so and the affordable
housing contribution is also very
pleasing so i'm just really happy
to support this application thank you
councillor and
councillor jerome i think you indicated
a question
i think i've got a quick question
pearson in the
energy budget statement they've
shortlisted four
possible areas in which they can reduce
their carbon budget by five percent
which i think is a requirement
i just wondered it do they can they pick
any one of those and is it something
they have to then prove to the council
that it meets that requirement or do
they
pick more than one and how does that
work
through youtube they think they need to
submit a scheme that's what the uh
the condition you know condition 27
yes condition twenty sevens that's the
final condition
requires them to submit a strategy so
really it's down to them to come forward
with a
series of options uh and we'll then
assess that of course
so um that
that's the work it would be nice if they
could go beyond
the the sort of regulation requirements
set out in the court strategy but
that may be okay i don't know but that's
all
we feel at the moment but it could be a
range of options
um i think the report highlights
thank you thank you and
councillor bigby
thank you very much in nature you know
it's a very attractive
design i i thoroughly appreciate it but
there
are issues and council accordingly
mentioned
in separation um in the report it
clearly says
that um there are distances which don't
conform
the apartments which will be um
not before regarding sunlight daylight
and they'll become potentially
um but by coming to the car parking
which has been mentioned by colleagues
you know there should be 221 places
but this well 17.
um i know there's um
it's been said that it will deter people
from
needing a car or wanting a car but
that's
that's a big wish there are three places
for people with mobility problems
well there could be more than three
people with mobility problems in a
place that size but it's not only
residents who live
in any apartment block who may need
require parking places
it's visitors it's doctors it's
engineers who visit the premises
you know it's only on any day there's
going to be doctors visiting apprentices
or engineers or service engineers
visiting
i know in manchester our friends who
live in manchester in
large in apartments where there's no
parking but in manchester
there are adequate pay car parks where
you can
park leave your car this location
there's none there's no off-road there's
no
on-road parking so i do think
i don't sit easy with it i i honestly
don't
but um i'll listen to what members think
thank you councillor um councillor
proctor
yeah we'd be quick very much echo what
uh council rupees just said actually i
i think it's a very attractive scheme i
like this
design um you know i could see
be a very good good place to live and
the
affordable housing uh proportion
percentage is
is is good um my two concerns
like council rigby is the car parking
spaces
now that's mitigated to some degree by
the public transport in that location
but there are you know issues with that
um
which i think just does concern me quite
a bit
and the other issue of that he also
mentioned
is the distance distance between the two
blocks i think it's going to be a degree
of overlooking
then i think that is picked up in the in
the report
so that that worries me a little bit but
i think overall i will revoke the scheme
but with
with those couple of concerns at the
back of my mind
and hopefully someone won't be able to
reassure me on those
thank you chair thank you councillor
councillor morgan
thank you chad i'm gonna echo councillor
rugby
council procter and uh what and brief
comment camps like
mentioned um i i've no scheme is perfect
and there are
things about this scheme i prefer that i
like and i don't like
but mostly in balance i would i actually
read it was really really in favor
and then i looked at the the car parking
allocation i just thought this is
ridiculous um i have to be honest i like
i i understand that there's 221 which is
the maximum
um and i i wouldn't have been highly
surprised if i've seen 221
parking spaces and i know it's great
public transport but
this is not a city center location i
mean there's
paragraph 182 that the lack of available
on um street parking and this will
encourage lower
levels of car parking ownership probably
to an extent but do i think that this it
would
will make people go you know what i've
got a car i'm going to sell this car
because i'm renting this flat
for example no it won't and i i really
have got real concerns about this this
is going to cause
people will park a decent distance
because they will have a car
and i i really have to say this really
does concern me this
and i really would like some reassurance
from officers about this
because i i think and just assuming
that saying 31 of residents don't turn
the car
well by my calculation 31 don't own that
comes to about 140 car parking spaces we
should be having
and council rugby's right the allocation
for
people who've got mobility issues or
other disabilities
um there's the workmen police officers
you know you know a flat this size will
have a relative
amount of trade and it really does
concern me
this um at the moment i i probably
recommend
i'm i'm unlikely to support this but on
this on this basis
the only thing but i do think that 17
car parking spaces
is is not enough for a a location which
is miles outside the city centre
thank you thank you councillor and
councillor hartley
thank you chair um i i actually have a
number of reservations about about the
application
um i'm not sure they are enough
to uh to mean the adverse impacts
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits but
um but i do have a number of concerns
you know it is it is an attractive
building the appearance
uh is good um so it said it so it looks
good but
the more i read in the report the more
sort of concerns i had really about the
immunity of the
of the living space um the civic quarter
area action plan is is referred to and
the report says that
now it's at the regular regulation 19
stage it uh it should be given
considerable weight
and uh is considered to be um a
determinative
document in in determining the
application and and
and this application fails to comply
with a lot of what is in the area action
plan to be honest um
it fails to comply on on the building
height um
although i appreciate it's on the sort
of on the board of the next zone where
higher buildings
uh are tolerated um paragraph 15 in the
report
sort of um sums up what what's um what's
set out in the in the area action plan
and what
residential development should should
seek to achieve so it talks about
immunity space which um you know should
have playable services play sculptures
playable hard landscape features the the
immunity space doesn't doesn't look that
good from what i can see
um council accordingly referred to the
national space standards and the and the
aap
says that that all units must or units
must
meet or exceed the national space
standards and and um
20 of 20 of the apartments don't um
it's a very high density building and
you know i sort of think they they could
reduce the density have a few less flats
and and then the flats probably all
would meet the national
uh minimum space standards um the air
action plan says
uh this should be um more than 50 of the
apartments should be dual aspect
majority of the flats in this in this
development a single aspect
and their action policies should avoid
north facing single aspect units and
they should only be permitted
for non-family dwellings and in
exceptional circumstances
there's no exceptional circumstances
identified in this application or in the
report that i can see
and 27 of the apartments have a sole
northern aspect and it looks like some
of those
could be used for um for family
accommodation because when you look at
the
the plans for each floor um
certainly in block b there's a number of
one bed flags which have a northern
aspect only
um on all the floors i think there's
also a two bed
flat um most on most of the floors in
the
northeast corner and it looks like that
has a solely northern aspect um
as well i know there are there aren't
many windows in the
eastern elevation of that block i think
that's the problem there are some but it
looks like they are windows
for stairwells possibly bathrooms which
would be
um obscured laced there's a similar
problem in
in block a as well to be honest i won't
go through it but again there's a number
of
apartments in there that have a seoul um
northern northern aspect and the bre
guidance is referred to in the
in the report um which says that
you know those apartments with a sole
northern north west northeastern aspect
should be minimized um unless it is
appealing view to the north well the
view to the north is is the back of
of white city retail park so um
so just i just have a number of of
concerns i'll try not to repeat what
other members have said
parking has been has been talked about
uh
the sunlight daylight hours has been
talked about
you know i went through the assessments
for that in in detail and you know
there's a number of windows or rooms
that fail to meet um those targets i
know i know that they are only targets
and the bre guidance
isn't a planning policy document
um and the report um the report makes
clear that
the um the the national planning policy
says there
is a there is a degree of uh flexibility
needed there which you know which i
would agree with particularly for
high density uh higher rise developments
like this but the the the national
planning policy framework does say that
there still needs to be acceptable
living standards and and my
my concern here is is that is that there
isn't
uh the immunity space i've mentioned i
think it's inadequate in terms of
the the size and the quality of it
um the i know the landscaping matches
are reserved but i think
the space on the site probably can't
accommodate the
specific green infrastructure that's um
that's required by spd1
and uh 5.4 in the in the core strategy
so i know there's a number of concerns
about it and i think
you know when we get to the conclusion
there aren't many adverse impacts
listed uh and i don't think that's right
i think there are a number
of other adverse impacts um
which have you know which i've tried to
refer to so the real question for me is
whether those adverse impacts um
significantly demonstrably out where the
benefits which which i accept a way to
accept the benefits and the the need you
know the the contribution it makes to
the housing need
the affordable housing allowance uh you
know it's a brownfield
site already developed they're all
really weighty factors so i
you know i think it's quite finely
balanced to be honest when you weigh up
all of the adverse impacts that i can
find against uh against those benefits
but um i'll wait and see what other
members say um
before uh before i decide which sort of
which side of that balance
i think we should fall thank you chair
thank you council i would just reflect
that
i think you've articulated a number of
my concerns and in fact i was quite
surprised really at the level of
enthusiasm for this application
that other members have expressed and i
think what it's exposed to me is that
you know well produced an attractive
looking
um visual images can can
really prove powerful and swaying a
person's view about an application
because
when you go into the fine details
contained in the committee report there
are a number of things that i found
concerning
members will know that a few weeks ago
we absolutely ripped apart an
application
on the basis that the the space standard
in a number of the
units was was not adequate and yet
here we we've got an application where
20 um
flats are below um what are
nationally uh defined space standards
in addition to that members will be
familiar with the fact that i don't like
it when applicant
applications come forward which only
propose
um a minimal amount of shadow of
affordable housing provision and i
appreciate it has increased from
the applicant's starting place but i
also don't appreciate it when
we only see shared ownership because if
you can't afford to buy
in trafford oftentimes you won't be able
to uh to afford to buy
the shared ownership component of
a rented owned property um
i think in addition to that you know
this is part of trafford that is rapidly
changing
uh hitherto now it hasn't really had
much in the way of residential
accommodation and i think we've had a
number of very big applications come to
committee recently which
when they come forward to development
stage have the
capacity to really change the feel for
this part of the bubba
uh as mr pearsons pointed out you know
this
the the height of one of the blocks is
significantly different to the existing
unit and i do wonder whether or not the
site can fully accommodate it or
and quite how when it comes to being
built it will change the feel of this
part
of the bubba i i think council hartley
has pointed to the fact that it's a fine
balance and i couldn't agree more there
are some welcome
aspects to the application i mean we
just had like i was
listening to the conversation previously
on the prior applications about
educational contribution it's welcome
that there's a full educational
contribution uh
in this application to this application
but as others have pointed out
the blocks are very close it's a dense
use
uh of this plot so it's an interesting
conversation
that we're having now um now council
carries also indicated that he'd like to
speak
so call him thank you
thank you chairman and i will be
supporting the um
application according to the office's
recommendations i think the report is
really good
i understand the point you've just been
made i thought they were really
interesting you and uh councillor
um hartley and my biggest thing was
parking at first
i was oh my god 17 spaces well it should
have 221
and then i thought well these 17 spaces
you know is
who's gonna have them can somebody buy
one can somebody rent them
are they free for all uh visitors and
then i thought well maybe
could we put a condition on that i don't
know and then when i read
um paragraph 181
it does explicitly state that the
perspective residential occupiers
whether that be purchase or renters will
be told
and be made aware explicitly
um about this um private ownership and
i kind of think you know
what we are trying to encourage more
people to use public transport
is right near the metro link it has got
lots of side corporation
maybe we give it a go and let the market
decide
um if this is going to work um
just something i thought about thank you
chairman
thank you councillor um mr pierce and i
think you're going to come in and
clarify and respond to some of the
comments
thank you chairman yes just trying to
respond to a number of our points that
have been raised
several points i think the first one
that seemed to come up was parking
um i mean obviously more generally um
members are aware of the sort of um
you know the aspirations in the aap
envisioned aap
um this is it is a very sustainable
location
you know it's it's a very short tram
ride from manchester city centre
i guess it's almost walkable from city
centre and we are trying to encourage
developers to to look at other means of
transport than the than the private car
um so that's one consideration um
the the other um is that you know if you
do provide a
lower number of parking spaces well then
what harm might result
now the harm that often results in
development schemes is that you get
on street parking outside other
established residential areas
now in our view this site was
sufficiently distant from any other
established residential areas that
i can't imagine anybody wanting to live
here
is likely to want their to park their
car overnight for example
outside the nearest residential street
that that's not got a residence only
parking
uh scheme on it that's quite some
distance away
um i mean concerns i think expressed as
well perhaps about emergency vehicle
access i mean there are always places
where
emergency vehicles can park if they need
to attend so
even with the slight layout um
so that's the sort of parking issue um
various comments uh raised really in
relation to
i think the general issue of immunity um
one was the separation distances between
the buildings i mean
yeah absolutely it is tight and yet
again
in the in the emerging aap and in the
emerging trafford design guide
for this type of development in this
type of area where
you're going to get high density
developments uh the separation distances
that we're used to looking
at in in spd or
pg-1 pg-1 new residential development
for example
are are not really going to apply in
areas like this
um and the thinking seems to be that
people who are likely to want to buy
into this sort of development
are going to be prepared to to
compromise on issues like that
so yes they are going to be overlooked
if they don't choose to install the
blind
at their window you know with the lights
on in the evening but
um that's that's one of the what one of
the aspects of living in this this
kind of development um
i mean in in terms of amenity talk was
mentioned was made of the
the nationally described space standards
now i mean the report
sets out that actually 86 percent of the
units do comply
those space stands now um the council
hasn't got to those space standards yet
so
and i think council heartlessly
mentioned that while the aap
um i suggest that all developments
should should
comply with those and once the aap is
adopted and that becomes the development
plan for this
part of the borough then that will be
the case that will be a
development plan requirement but at the
moment it's not
and given how short the or how close the
scheme
may be there's just there are 20 of the
two bed units that are short they fall
only between two and six square meters
short so again on balance because we've
not got adopted standards we felt that
that was acceptable
i know um uh mention was made of the
comparison between this scheme and one
or two of the other schemes that we've
seen
and i think committee refused lately
this scheme
is in terms of its general level of
amenity we think is far
far far better than those schemes
um also on the the general issue of
um at the aap again it talks about
trying to avoid north-facing
problems that have slowly north-facing
aspects now
fully acknowledge that this is one one
aspect of this scheme where
it really does fall short um and yet
we've got
we've got a sort of a length of tolbert
road
where the building lines are already
established really
um and they are they generally buildings
onto
the road they have a north south aspect
and and that's kind of unavoidable if
you want a building to front the street
which is appropriate in street scene
terms then
on this road you can't help but have a
north-facing airspace
um yes a lot of the the units do have a
north
facing aspect but those that are that
rise above the general level of the
uh buildings in the area will at least
have a distant view
um so again on on balance we felt that
that was probably acceptable
um mentioned was made of sunlight and
daylight
impact uh as well and yes again we
you know it's not fully compliant most
schemes are
rarely fully compliant but again we feel
this is
this just about hit the balance um and
again
it is mentioned i think in the report
that the bre guidelines
weren't written for developments like
this the
sort of much smaller scale suburban
development so i hope i've
covered uh most of the points that
members raised there
and um i i would just conclude that on
balance
yeah not everything's perfect it never
is but when you throw everything into
the mix
and the design quality we we thought
this was
overall you know the benefits of the
scheme outweigh the
the adverse impact so that's why we've
made
the recommendation that we have um we do
believe it should look
um it should look a little look like a
good quality development
and will offer a decent level of amina
t4 for residents
thank you shanna thank you mr pearson um
as i have noted um
the application has been proposed to be
accepted by council accordingly but now
the
um no other them his second did as far
as i can tell if any of them
thank you councillor um as it's now been
composed and seconded that we
uh approved the application i think in
the interest of time we'll move to the
votes and i'll ask members
as you appear on my screen and counselor
victory
thank you councillor councillor jerome
i support officer's recommendation to
grant thank you councillor councillor
hartley
sorry chair um i can't support it i
don't think i've got i've got too many
reservations about it i suspect
um other members are in favor but uh i'm
going to
vote against the officer recommendation
thank you councillor councillor minis
um i've got too many reservations i
think i'm going to have to go um against
sorry thank you councillor councillor
proctor
uh yeah i have some reservations but i
will
accept the officer's recommendation to
grant
thank you councillor council accordingly
okay you came on me much quicker than
that because
um yeah i i'm accepting the um
application um
except the recommendation thank you
thank you councillor councillor canola
um i'd like to accept it but
do you know what i'm sick of so many
flats and not enough houses and not
enough social housing
and um it just feels like a big project
that's been developed
to make money so no i don't support it
thank you councillor councillor morgan
um against officer recommendations
thank you councillor councillor dr
parkley
thank you chairman i did ask to speak
before you went to the vote i just want
to make a very brief comment and to say
that
um you did say that perhaps we were
swayed or particular members of the
committee were swayed by good
cgi computer generated images i would
like to say from my personal point of
view
that was not the case at all i just
thought on balance it was a good scheme
and an attractive scheme
and therefore i support officer
recommendation thank you thank you
councillor
council of acting to support the
recommendations chair
thank you councillor councillor carrie
i support the application uh thank you
chairman
thank you councillor and i will be
voting
against officer recommendation so i make
it that's
five votes against to seven votes in
favor
so the application is approved
and the next application for
consideration is we cheap hotel
which is on page one of the committee
report
and it will be introduced by ms kohling
thank you chairman if you just bear with
me by like
share my screen second
okay is everybody able to see that
yeah okay yeah thank you um this this
application relates to the
wheat chief hotel which is on the 1856
on the northern approach to ultra town
center
but what's on the corner of church
street west um
which is which is the a56 knoll field
road uh to the north
uh and there are is bound by a boarding
and victorian dwellings
um there's some open grassed areas here
um and then the uh georgian dragon hotel
is on the opposite side
of um of church street and then beyond
that there's a uh
just off the top of this plan here is a
um
listed uh region on sunday
road the site's within the sandy way
conservation area which which is
centered around that terrace
um and the building is noted in the
conservation area
as both a positive contribution and a
landmark building
uh there's another conservation area in
the in the vicinity old marketplace
conservation area in the boundary runs
there along the wall
um this is the existing site plan here
you can see um you can see the the
building and the um
the numerous additions and alterations
the cobbled area that's probably
familiar to
anybody who's driven past the site it is
very prominent on the on the road
is is here at the front with old field
road going up to john lee
the park at the back um
unfortunately the plans are quite small
to show on
on the screen um but these are the these
are the existing
elevations um
and then we have the um grounds
ground floor and site plan here so the
applicant proposes to redevelop the site
to provide six plannings
through the conversion of the most
important prominent original
elements the front of the plot together
with the demolition of single story
elements the rear
the detached garage along the plots
northwest boundary
and these these elements at the rear are
to be replaced by a combination of
single story and two-story rear
extensions
and a new carport store so if i go into
the next slide
but you can see that this isn't
particularly again the drawings have got
a lot of detail on them which don't
transfer
well to the to the slideshow so i've
split this particular
site plan up into two um and also
um rotated it so that you look
effectively looking at the front of the
building back so this is so what you'll
see here is
is the rear part of the site and you can
see the the red dotted line there
is um is a
is is a line of demolition
you can see a unit here which is number
six
you see garden areas here which are
which
exist at the moment would convert it to
be used by them then you've got
um bin store there car parking further
car parking cycle store
courtyard and then further accommodation
here
so if i go down to the next slide that
will start to make some more sense
effectively this this overlaps and
continues that down
if you've got the remainder of the
communal areas
from the front parts the front parts of
the building here
you can see the demolition quite clearly
there there's a coach
coach access which you'll see on the
elevations there and then the court
the cobbled courtyard area sorry not
caught your dairy frontage area
at that point so proposed from
television as you can see
uh retains the historic elements of
of the building uh in in situations and
simply converts the space behind them
the real elevation you see there uh
there are
several extensions in order to
accommodate that residential
accommodation
and again these these side elevations
you've got the um
mount street property up there that you
can see that relationship
and then the building at the front
vintage there
and then the extensions in this part
again you can see this with the
courtyard
then in the courtyard there's this
single story um
unit one bedroom dwelling there and the
carports
um isn't that blank
like for some reason the remainder of
the slides seem to have disappeared so
if you just bear with me while i try and
try and get those back
right if you just bear with me they
should work again
okay so you can see the the in here that
that's showing the area
in there and then you've got the carport
uh so that's that part there and then
the carport bin store
there and the front elevation the car
cycle store which is just there
that's a lower ground floor plan showing
that there's some accommodation the
basement with light wells
the first floor and then the reef plan
the section plans which we've seen
before and then there's just a couple of
cgi's
seek to model the building
um this application has been reported to
committee because we've had seven
lessons objection which has been
contributed to the office of
recommendation
key issues here that are the principle
of residential development
heritage design and residential immunity
impacts
and the principle of residential
development sites considered to be
acceptable
um it would be acceptably designed and
and uh immunity impacts have been
carefully considered and
deemed to be acceptable no highways
concerns
um the heritage officer has been
consulted on the application has worked
hard with the case officer and with the
applicant to to get to a scheme that
that that um she's happy with
um she does identify that there would be
moderate harm
to the heritage asset as a result of the
proposals
with this scale of intervention but
nonetheless it's considered that
the ability to bring this this important
landmark building back into a viable
permanent viable use whilst retaining
its most important features
are is is something which does outweigh
uh that that moderate harm um deemed
less substantial
in nppf terms um
and additionally there would be of
course the contribution to the borough's
housing land supply
uh no harm incidentally has been
identified to the setting of the
greater listed terrorists to the
northeast consequently the application
is recommended for approval subject
thank you chairman
thank you miss coley um there's one
speaker to this application
speaking against it i believe um it's
hello can you hear me um yeah
is it it's dominique ross's wife
oh that's fine um you've got three
minutes to speak to mrs
mervis and if you do run over time i'll
just politely ask that you
uh wrap up your remarks thank you
okay thank you and i'm a resident of to
the grove
and thank you for allowing me to speak
today overall we are in support
of the development however we would like
to raise several concerns
number one plans to demolish and replace
the existing garage block
the documents detailing the exact plans
for the existing garage blocks were only
submitted for us to
view yesterday and after the planning
office's report was written
it is worth noting that several revised
plans have been submitted after the
planning office's report has been
written
the proposed height of the ridge of the
carport is lower than the existing
garage block
and the card port block is shorter at
the south side being replaced with a
bike shed at a lower level
both of these changes would affect our
privacy no provision has been made to
fill this gap
with screenings such as a fence at the
same height
as the existing garage block we are also
concerned about the proposed demolition
of the garages
due to height differences between the
proposed development and our property
the removal of the back wall and
supporting buttress walls
should be assessed by a structural
engineer prior to removal
as there are the potential risk of
collapse of pathways of to the grove
and our property itself an insurance
policy should
be taken out by the builder in case of
damage to our property
due to subsidence and a copy of this
lodged with us
number two the planting of 18 trees on
the site
the planning office's report paragraph
89
states that 18 trees should be planted
three for each dwelling
there is limited garden space a large
portion of which is the communal garden
neighboring our patio
where there are currently no high trees
or shrubs
the original landscaping master plan
dated the 7th of february 2020
appeared to only show two significant
feature trees in the communal garden
we are concerned that the 18 trees will
be overly concentrated along our
boundary
and lead to a significant reduction in
light to our patio area
such intense tree planting would also
risk impacting the surrounding
foundations and drains
number three the proposal to no longer
use
obscured glazing in the window of
bedroom 4
of dwelling 5. we object to this
proposal
all other facing windows at this level
including another bedroom and living
room
use obscured glazing we have no issue
with the proposed new window for
dwelling two bedroom two
and finally the refuse store we remain
opposed to the placement of the refuse
store
the planning statement report itself
cites trafford core strategy policy
l7 on page 21 which we understand
protects existing neighbours
and states development must be
compatible with the surrounding
area and not prejudice the immunity of
the occupants of adjacent properties
by noise or particularly in this case
odor in any other way
there appear to be viable alternative
sites including swapping car parking
spaces one and two
a portion of the garage area in dwelling
five
or to the entrance of the development
which would also make
bin collection easier thank you very
much
thank you mr mervis and council
accordingly i think you've indicated
you'd be happy to open the discussion
um yeah um i'm happy to propose um
acceptance of the application although
i do think uh some of the issues raised
by the uh speaker
are worthy of uh addressing my
understanding is some of the questions
over
structural stability and um need to be
um they're not they're out with the
planning application um i'd be very
disturbed if i was granting something
that would bring
um that would cause financial liability
but
so i think we need to make sure where
does the planning application
go and the boundaries of the planning
application there is some question over
shared walls and things like that and i
do agree uh
they need to be addressed but otherwise
um the application is to a listed
building
that is falling into real distribute
over the years
uh it's not going to come back as a pub
um it's not um it's not in a sustainable
place for a pub
anymore ultra good town centre's moved
so i think my main concern is that this
actually preserves that what is
an absolutely uh important feature of
the
main road in altering them and on that
basis i propose it but i do have
concerns over
shared walls and things like that over
the carports
thank you councillor was myself
trying to check the additional
information report as mrs mobis was
speaking because i think she did raise a
number of
questions that perhaps after we've heard
from another couple of speakers
ms scott you might be in a position to
respond to um
counselor jerome you've also indicated
you'd like to ask a question
not a question but i would like to speak
if that's okay
thank you
yeah i'm also um inclined to support
this uh
uh application too and the heritage
development officer i think has has been
quite
quite clear and i think he has got it
right
the works will result in moderate harm
to the significance of the wheat sheath
and its context however the conversion
and the reuse of this vacant and
deteriorating landmark
building is welcomed and i would agree
with that i mean this is an important
landmark
in an important conservation and
heritage area for ultragun
we cannot take this application lightly
however this
building has sadly fallen into
dereliction
over the last few years and it it's not
viable as a pub we know we've got the
georgian dragon nearby
and the old market tavern as well as a
number of other pubs in in notre dame
town centre so i don't think it is
viable as a pub anymore which is very
sad
um but a fact i believe i would like to
also thank the officers for the work
they've done on this application
i believe they've worked hard with the
applicant to retain the key heritage
features
and have a consistent design and
treatment of materials to be consistent
with the surrounding kind of
conservation area
and this change of youth will contribute
to much needed housing as well in in a
sustainable location
um issues raising objections though
difficult i
do think the report has dealt with these
i sympathize with the neighbors regard
the bin store
and i'm just wondering whether uh miss
coley could
could look at the bin stores and see if
they could be moved to a better location
i'm wondering
if this is quite a small issue really
and can be dealt with
um which i think would be helpful um
but i think also you know with the bin
store if residents
do use the bins correctly and and
properly and
and work within the council rules then
the bin store isn't actually as big as a
problem
uh as you would like to think and not
one that we can really reject an
application on
but if we if we can move them that would
be fantastic
i think the boundary wall insurance
matter is a legal matter
and i hope that does get sorted and i
think in the additional information
report the 18 trees has been downscaled
to 10 trees
um as i think the council does recognize
that 18 trees
it is too big for for the plot we're
talking about
um but um i'm also going to
um support a council accordingly
proposal so i'm happy to second that
on this application and i think overall
the officers have done a good job
and this will be a a massive improvement
to what's currently situated on site
so thank you chair thank you councillor
um
councilman morgan you you have asked if
you couldn't submit a question
thank you chair yeah yeah um um i'd
broadly
really support her of this and agree
with everything that councillor jerome
has just said i've just got two
questions that
i think are really quite hopefully
really important first there was
something in the report about
the flammability of zinc i haven't got a
clue about this i do remember zing from
science experiments but um
just um i think it's on one of the roofs
um just if one of the officers could
just confirm on that that
there is any flammability risk and then
just on highways
um i think this is coming out onto the
main road from what i can gather i have
to be honest i struggled with some of
the um
diagrams of this um and just i just if
mr pearson could just confirm in terms
of highway
safety and sustainability it's a pretty
busy road particularly at
um peak times um so that's just my two
questions thank you
would you like me to take those now
chairman yeah okay
um so in terms of the highways
um the uh the access
um i mean i can share the planet plan
again if it if it would be helpful
in fact i will do because i i don't
think i can describe
describe it effectively unless i do um
so if you just bear with me while that
while that loads up
um right can you
are you saying the same as i am there
side elevation one or two
cgi just shout up if you are um
yeah you are can you see the underpass
where my cursor is
that's that's that's the um that's the
access
so it so you wouldn't come straight out
onto the main road
there you would come out onto oldfield
road
right it's it's it's set back from the
main i mean i suppose
well you could but uh from my own
knowledge of the site you'd have a
pretty big curb to
bump down um and so it's
so it's kind of just quickly then
because oldfield itself do you have to
mean at peak times can be pretty
busy so let's say someone wants to go
drive into town do that to me that
the middle of the day if you're not in
the middle of the day at peak hours just
being like outside of coco
who knows where the real world will be
but let's let's pretend it goes back to
where we are
um it's pretty difficult i'm just
i'm just thinking in my head you're not
going to get some people trying to be
ridiculous
and then similarly people turning on to
old field road
highway security safety aspect
well i mean the highway authority have
not i've not objected to to this and if
i don't answer this
uh satisfactory then then i might bring
might bring jeff in
but i think for this
you can't take it from a null position
it what it was a pub it might not have
been a pub for a while
but it could become a pub again tomorrow
so
so it has to bear in mind the level of
traffic that you would get from
from a pub and this use would be
much less than that the other thing of
course is this is a historic building
so you might if you were if you were if
you were looking at the site
uh and you demolish everything and put
an access in off
old field road that would that would
make some sense if you had a clear sight
but you don't have that
and the benefits of retaining those
front parts of the building particularly
when you've got a fallback position of a
pub use
um i think would outweigh any concerns
about
maneuvers which have no doubt taken
place um
over over many years
i i appreciate that and accept that
thank you um you had another question
which in all the excitement i've
forgotten completely so
if you remind me of it i'll answer
there's a comment about
zing there's there was a comment about
zinc on some of the roofs and it was
flammable
i can't remember i might have missed it
being answered
no i didn't i'd forgotten i'd forgotten
that i remembered you'd asked a question
but not the detail
um zinc is a relatively common um
roofing material for contemporary
buildings and is used in a number of
uh houses and apartment schemes um in
the south of the borough
and there has never been any any issues
obviously if it's not properly insulated
then that would be an issue with the
with it what was behind it as opposed to
the material itself
is there any scope for moving the bin
store within this scheme
sorry i couldn't get myself off mute
there um we've asked that question a
number of times cancer and the answer
is no um the uh
it would require completely reorganizing
the the
rear accommodation and and wouldn't work
for the scheme
officers have considered careful
position of the bin store it's not
uncommon to have this kind of
relationship
on a par on apartments or schemes like
this with with neighboring properties
and they don't usually cause any issues
we have to assume that they will be used
responsibly
thank you um the application has been
proposed and seconded now and no other
members have indicated in the
chat that they're looking to speak
because it is if anybody does want to
make a further contribution if you just
perhaps do so now or otherwise i i think
we're in a position to move
to the vote really
as it's been proposed and seconded i
think if we proceed straight to vote and
councillor rick b
chairman yes you councillor councillor
jerome i also support officer's
recommendation to graham
thank you councillor councillor hartley
thank you
sports recommendation thank you
councillor councilman
support officer recommendation to grant
thank you councillor councillor
i support uh chairman thank you thank
you councillor councillor dr barkley
thank you chairman i support the
officer's recommendation to grant
thank you councillor councillor doctor
uh councillor morgan
support officer recommendation to grant
thank you councillor councillor
accordingly
support officer's recommendation to
grant chair
thank you council the council of acting
councillor antony he's still on the call
yourself dave yeah i i'm i'm for the
application thank you councillor and i i
will also be voting
uh in line with officer recommendations
a grant and
that application is approved um the next
application for consideration is
uh gulmar on garden lane which is page
256 of the committee report
and will be introduced by ms coley i
understand
thank you chairman um just bear with me
while i share my screen
okay
all right
just bear with me um my introduction
yes
one okay
thank you thank you for your patience um
this application uh
is being reported to the planning
committee as it's been called in by
council welton
has also received a further nine letters
of objection to a local resident
all the representations are summarized
in the offices report and in the
additional information report
and generally relate to the key issues
of design impact on residential immunity
impact on the conservation area and
highway safety
the application site is currently
occupied by a detached bungalow
with small garden areas uh sighted to
the north and south
building the western boundary of the
site with garden lane is formed by a mix
of brick walling
fencing and the rendered sidewall of the
property
the bungalow is vacant and dilapidating
the garden areas overgrown with areas
hard standing springfield a detached
storm of bungalow
and a parking area used by nearby
offices are located to the west of the
site
to the north is a recent development of
a pair of semi-detached houses with
gates access off garden lane
four-story office block with associated
parking is sighted to the south of gold
mark
the rear gardens properties on
springfield road
lie beyond the eastern boundary these
gardens are approximately 0.9 of a meter
lower than gold mark
and they slope down towards the rear of
the dwellings which are approximately
two meters low in the application site
these dwellings are substantial detached
and semi-detached victorian properties
with three floors of above ground
accommodation
the the site is located within character
area c
church street commercial area of the old
marketplace conservation area
planning permission is a store for the
demolition of the existing building
and direction of a two-story
three-number bedroom
uh dwelling along with new replacement
boundary walls and landscaping
so that's the existing dwelling is as is
seen on the site now
um that's the proposed site site plan so
you can see
the new uh the new footprint of the
dwelling there
garden area and parking space there was
a detached garage proposed for that area
of the site which has been removed
at the request of officers uh that's a
zoomed in version so you can see the you
can see the floor plans there
you see uh ground floor plan parking
spaces and the accommodation in the roof
there
um these are the elevations uh rear
elevation that would be
facing on to the properties on
springfield road that's the garden lane
elevation that faces into the garden
south and that
and that face is onto the to the garage
sorry not the garage the parking area
um these are some contextual elevations
showing
how the building sits within the
surrounding context
in particular i'd just like to to uh
draw your attention to this i mean it's
one of the previous reasons for refusal
and significant concern has been um
expressed about the impact of this
building on properties on springfield
road
so you can see there that there is 22
meters between
this um rear elevation here and the
two-story part of the
uh of the properties on springfield road
uh albeit um one of the properties does
have
does have some single story outriggers
bit beyond there
um so that more than complies with our
um guidance in in spd-1 in terms of
separation distances if you had a blank
gable here which which you do
effectively and which would be somewhat
taller as well
so it's just useful to show that in
context there again this shows
this shows the sections in in context
and then there's some there's some
photographs
um
i will go back to contextual elevations
the previous application for replacement
dwelling on this site was refused in
january
2018 contrary to officer recommendation
and
three reasons relating to design impact
on neighbouring properties and highway
safety
this application seeks to address those
reasons for refusal by reducing the
height
massing and size of the proposed
property and utilizing a traditional
design approach
officers considered that the previous
reasons for refusal have been
successfully addressed
and the proposed development will result
in acceptable form of development
with regards to immunity of neighbouring
future residents ecology drainage
highways access and parking the visual
impact on the street sea
would not harm the significance of the
conservation area subject to the
inclusion of the conditions you see in
your report
the local highway authority have
carefully considered the proposals
and have raised no objection the
application is therefore recommended
for approval thank you chairman
thank you ms kobe and that there's a
number of speakers to this
uh item i believe two speakers against
i'm not sure if
councillor welton and dr neil did
discuss
between them who'd like to speak first
um hi it's kerry nield here i'm happy to
speak first if that's
helpful yeah that's great thank you dr
neil and you've got three minutes to
speak and if you do run over time i'll
just politely request that you conclude
your contribution thank you
okay thank you chair and councillors i
live at 3 springfield road
we do not object to the development of
the property at its existing height and
scale
the neighbors welcome planning permit
and planning granted in october 2017
under permitted development which retain
the character and height of the existing
with minimal impact to surrounding
properties and conservation area
residents subject to the current
application the site was refused
planning in 2018
due to residential amenities highways
and conservation the reasons for reviews
will remain with this application
the application is higher nearly two
meters higher
and wider than that refused in 2018 the
site is just over the half a width of a
cricket
wicket or bowling alley and the
applicant wants to stack the equivalent
height of two double decker buses on top
of each other in this space
the result is a three-story property
from the perspective of springfield
which is higher than the original walls
around strange ways and three times the
height of the berlin wall
the application is oppressive and
overbearing
the applicant suggests moving the
property one metre further away from the
boundary
and the sloping roof observes this
nearly two meters increase in height
from the previous application this is
just absurd
from the straight on angle facing our
homes a nearly 10 meter high wall is
still
a 10 meter high wall whether it is brick
or slate roof
whether it is two or three strides away
from the boundary
it is not the same as a two meter gable
that is less than five meters as
suggested in the report
gardens on springfield already feel like
being at the bottom of a bowl due to the
hill
if the application would prove this
would be putting a lid on that bowl
and the develop would completely block
the sun we will be in total shadow
it's especially important when the
garden is all my children have access to
in the covert 19 pandemic
the link between vitamin d and
preventing kovid shows how important
light is to the immunity of residents
shadowing will be live out of the
refused application the height
difference between the properties on
springfield and the site
is the aggravating factor as
acknowledged by this committee
in refusing previous applications and
agreed by the planning inspectorate
the properties are closely sided as the
building is on infill site at the
gardens of
springfield road the distances to
surrounding houses
habitable rooms and garden boundaries
are far
far short the guidelines there is no
distance for overbearing
and oppression it is a matter of
judgment the windows has
the department has windows and major
habitual rooms which allow overlooking
directly line of sight into my
children's bedrooms
the planning report acknowledges this
but the suggested mitigations would not
prevent
this light of sight into our properties
ours are family homes
with small children and safeguarding
must be considered
in summary the proposed dwelling is
overbearing oppressive
visually intrusive and overshadowing
we'll be hemmed in
and we'd need to turn on lights even at
the height of summer we'll be overlooked
by windows
in direct line of sight into children's
bedrooms our lives and enjoyment of our
homes will be significantly affected if
an application was granted
we would like the property be developed
under the permitted development
but this would be oppressive i only ask
that you exercise your sound judgment
as you did previously and refuse this
application
on several planning grounds thank you
also to the committee members who came
to visit the site
thank you thank you dr neil um
councillor welton uh you will have five
minutes for your contribution and
as i've said previously if you have run
slightly i'll just ask that you back up
your remarks thank you
thank you very much chair can you hear
me okay
yeah go ahead thank you
i'm very happy to be following in my
predecessor michael young's footsteps in
opposing a two-story development on this
site
on behalf of the residents of
springfield road and garden lane
it's disappointing that we're here again
when a bungalow is so obviously the
perfect fit for this plot
and the owner already has planning
permission for an extension to the
current property
a one-story development on this site
would have got permission a long time
ago
instead the owner has allowed the
existing building to deteriorate
while chasing permission for a two-story
development that is unsuitable for this
site
a quick look at right move will show you
that there are multiple three bedroom
bedroom houses on the market
close to the center of ultra and more
being built but there is currently only
one bungalow for sale and none in the
town centre
stair-free houses with an easy walking
distance of the town center are very
rare
and this application seeks to remove one
which could eat it ideally which could
ideally suit residents with mobility
issues
for this reason i'll argue that this
application will negatively impact the
housing stock in auction
whilst causing undue harm to the lives
of those living in the neighborhood
neighboring properties on springfield
and garden lane due to issues of over
massing and highways conflict
yeah this committee rejected the
previous application for this site on
three points that it failed to preserve
the character of the conservation area
that it would
appear overbearing invisibly intrusive
and
would potentially cause conflict between
highways users
of these three points only the first has
been addressed to any extent by this new
proposal
but still manages to contravene
conservation area policy on dormer
windows
0.2 has been made worse during due to
the increased height and width of the
roof
and the highways concerns raised in 0.3
have not been remedied at all
with regards to the conservation area
section 35 of the planning office's
report points out that buildings with
normal windows are not normally
acceptable in the conservation area
but then fails to weigh the proposed
normal window in its consideration of
the replacement dwelling
given the dormer window is vital to this
project thanks to the large height and
size of the roof
it could be said that the whole basis of
this two-story project rests on a
contravention of conservation policy 65.
if from the outset the architects had
made the choice to abide by the rules
pertaining to the conservation area the
design would not have ended up looking
like this
to grant planning permission would be to
reward the architect for flouting the
rules
with regards to massing the design and
access statement claims that this
development retains to quote
a similar relationship to the existing
house like some of you i have stood in
the garden of three springfield road and
found that this statement simply does
not stack up
unlike the five meter high roof that
will loom over three springfield and its
neighbors
the roof will cut off a huge amount of
natural light from their south facing
gardens and is therefore contrary to
policy l7 of the trafford core strategy
the fact that the roof is pitched will
not compensate given its height and
width and the angle to the properties on
springfield road
this is clearly demonstrated in the
architectural diagram of relative
heights provided in the objection by
five springfield road
residents on springfield also have
legitimate privacy concerns with the
facing windows on the east end elevation
the difference is 21.4 meters to five
springfield and 18.4 meters to three
springfield these distances are less
than 20
27 meters recommended in the spg one
guidelines
the design will also seriously impact on
the property at eight garden lane
during my visit there the sun was
directly above the office blocks on
victoria street but would have been
blocked by the proposed roof at gold
mark
cutting off natural light to number
eight's garden and rear windows
as this is a demolition and rebuild
local residents are within their right
to expect the highways
the highways issues with the existing
site are addressed
instead this proposal simply replicates
the issues that are already there
access to the parking space cuts
directly across the gates to eight and
ten garden lane
as demonstrated to me by a resident of a
vehicle reversing out of these
neighboring properties would be
unsighted to a vehicle exiting gulmarg
with a substantial risk of collision the
lha collision data for the last five
years
mentioned in the office's report cannot
be used as evidence of an absence of
risk because the existing property has
lain vacant for that whole period
the second lha report issued only today
looks at 10 years of statistics however
the houses at 8 and 10 garden lane were
only built in 2015
since when gulmar has been unoccupied to
put it simply the potential for conflict
between vehicles leaving these
properties has yet to be tested
and the committee must make up its mind
own mind about whether this experiment
is worth the risk in the written
objections to this proposal there are
further issues raised with boundaries
landscaping and bat habitat
however in conclusion i will return to
the issue of over massing
which i believe con causes the most
significant harm with regards to this
proposal
this application is significantly worse
for the residents of springfield road
than even the previously
rejected proposal on this basis i hope
the committee will follow the lead of
its predecessor
in 2018 and reject this scheme thank you
very much chair
thank you councillor welton and there is
a speaker um
in favor of the application i believe
that a
written statement has been submitted to
be read out uh i'm
not entirely is it ms lowe's are you yes
thank you miss i'll read that out now
thank you
and statement regarding the application
for planning permission to demolish and
replace goalmark
garden lane with a new family home
they're counsellors
neighbours and planning team members i'm
the applicant and i submit the following
background to this application
my parents have lived on garden lane
since 2000
and prior to that on barrington road
since 1977.
i grew up in altringham attended
altering altering him grammar
altering him has been good to us and we
hold it very dear
in 2015 our neighbor the then owner of
goldmark moved into a nursing home and
we hoped to move
and hoped to move out of the property
but given the property's run down nature
it was difficult to find a buyer
my father a good friend of our neighbor
asked me to buy gull mark for two
reasons
to help our neighbour and also so i
could live nearby as my father was
getting old
for these reasons i pissed i purchased
school mark even though the property had
seen better days
after acquiring the property it became
evident that it was not well designed or
in good shape
after consulting some professionals we
decided to build a new home which would
make it more desirable living space
and a positive contributor to the
neighborhood since 2018 the current
architect and i have been working hard
on the design
of the house making two pre-applications
prior to this current application
we have re-worked the design a number of
times and worked closely with the local
planning team and conservation officer
we aimed for a top-notch design which
respected the conservation area
we also sought to reduce the impact of
the house by pulling the design away
from the eastern boundary
further than the required minimum
distance distance from the houses on
springfield road
we've also dropped the fourth bedroom
and made the height of the design less
than the two houses next door eight and
ten garden lane
on the suggestion of the local planning
team we have also dropped the garage
we have actively sought to make the
design acceptable
having a family home next to my father's
home is the background
background gold marg has poorly designed
bungalow with only one and a half
bedrooms and cannot serve as a home
to any family but on top of that is also
a desire to address the current
poor use of the site i hope you can
consider
favorably this application to allow the
site to be replaced by a well-designed
family home
though it can be a more positive
contributor to our wonderful town
thank you for listening and letting me
share this background paul lee
thank you number of members have
indicated that they'd like to speak with
i think mrs coley you've asked if you
could just provide some clarification in
response to
some of the contributions we've received
so far
yes thank you sherman just just some uh
just some
clarifications the the gardeners on
springfield were described as being
south facing they're not they've faced
almost due west
um which is obviously important in terms
of the sun path
and the consideration um it was also
mentioned that the inspectorates
um uh also supported the previous
refusal there was no appeal
so uh that that also that also wasn't
that wasn't the case that the response
was not an appeal but to bring back a
revised application
and also um the application for
extensions was
um was a permitted development
application it's been um
understandably slowly described as as
permitted development planning
permission
it was a certificate of lawfulness for
to um determine that the
applications could sorry the extensions
could be erected under privity
development so just
just to clarify that thank you
thank you ms cardi and councillor jerome
i did have a very quick question just to
ask um in
in the offices of report um 0.67
in the last couple of sentences it says
it is therefore considered that due
to the level differences in short
distance to the shared boundary that
additional screening is necessary along
the eastern boundary
it's considered that a suitably worded
condition requiring such treatment would
mitigate any potential
for overlooking or loss of privacy to
the occupiers
of springfield road i just wondered if
that
is that condition enforceable if they
would take the screening away after a
number of years
um apologies i was on me thank you thank
you chairman
um if you're happy with me to answer
that now yes it would be enforceable
um just trying to turn up the
conditioning yes
the the conditioning question is
condition number eight
the final sentence of that um condition
is the structure shall there after be
retained
therefore they would need to to to stay
there
the council could enforce is it yes yeah
yes
okay um if you don't mind sheriff i'll
just go to my uh
response as well if that's okay yes
do you just think to complement your
point counselor jerome i do wonder
how the condition would be enforced i
mean
what what mechanism would that be
enforced through because is the ultimate
risk
the planning permission be withdrawn
could you just elaborate on the
enforcement process i suppose is what
i'm asking sorry
so certainly so um assuming that the
the development is um is
is granted on the plans and is and is
built in accordance with the approved
plan so that
that background obviously if it wasn't
it would be a slightly different process
uh somebody moves into the property and
then
proceeds to take to take that screening
away or lower the height of that
screening
um we would i i mean
i'd be quite open we would be reliant on
a complaint to to take action
um and uh but at that point
we would um we would either be able to
serve a brief
condition notice uh because because
there would be a breach or just a
straight enforcement notice
um because it would no longer be built
in in accordance with the
approved plans we would need to consider
harm and ex and
and expediency so if they'd
knocked 10 centimeters off it and and
you know and
a reasonable person standing in the
garden couldn't see anything you know
then we we unlike we would take action
so so we would still have to assess the
merits of course
we do in every enforcement case um but
but we would
there is a mechanism uh and a relatively
straightforward mechanism in which to
enforce that condition
and i suppose and counselor
you're indulging me now and interrupting
you i'm sorry i suppose what i'm asking
is
you know what's the end tool that the
council has
once you've served the notice where do
we go then if the notice isn't
adhered to when um residents says well
i'm just going to ignore it
we're not putting the screening back uh
well uh
breach of an enforcement notice is a
criminal offence that's at the point in
which planning
breaches move from being civil to
criminal um so
ultimately we we would we would be able
to pros we would be able to prosecute
whether again there's a right of appeal
against an enforcement notice it's not
i don't think you would you would go
directly from uh breach to prosecution
but again that that method of of dealing
with with this
is is there right so so it becomes
a matter for the courts to resolve yes
yes it
it would be yeah thank you for
clarifying that and sorry cancer george
to do that that's okay it's a good
question because i'm sure this really
happens that
it gets to that stage but uh um
this application i thought was tricky to
begin with but i don't think it is
um the application does have some good
aspects about
it i believe the materials and the
design of the building are in keeping
with the newly built houses at the end
of garden lane
and it would improve upon the current
building which requires updating
tidying and detracts from the current
street scene um
however residents have put some serious
objections to this application which i
believe the officer's report doesn't
mitigate
the the new ridge height and the
increase from the one story
to two does cause serious problems with
over massing
overbearing and over development of the
plot the new height will cut off
sunlight to springfield road gardens in
the early afternoon on summer and autumn
days and i think
miss coley makes that point clearer when
she talks about the garden being
um west facing because as the sun
travels over
it will be blocked out as it as it comes
to early afternoon
um and the pre previous application was
refused in 2018
and it's very very clear that the virtue
of its sighting
scale design and external experience and
it goes on to say by virtue of its
sighting height and massing in
conjunction
in conjunction with the elevated
position of the site would appear
overbearing
and visually intrusive and would unduly
overshadow
these properties to the detriment of
residential immunity
nothing has really changed and we were
talking about a flat roof
application which was around about 1.5
meters lower than the current
application
um so on the highway issues i also tend
to agree with
councillor welton and i don't think it's
fully being tested
and i think the residents have got some
really compelling
and well informed arguments here um so
overall
i will be rejecting this application and
i'll be going against officers
recommendation i'm happy to propose that
and i urge um fellow councillors on the
committee
to follow the same suit and and look at
that over massing
overbearing and loss of residential
immunity as reasons for
rejecting um officers recommendation
thank you chair
thank you councillor and council
accordingly
thank you chair um i'm not going to
support uh councillor jerome
in his uh refusal um
i have a lot of sympathy with it i have
been to the i i did visit the back
garden
of um the springfield park um i have a
lot of sympathy but it's mainly sympathy
with the topography
of that it's on a hill um
i can't make um allowances
for the hill every house is above is
going to be higher than the
the house below it's it's it's it's a
physical absurdity to think that you
wouldn't
um the ho the plot is a really small
plot
um it this is a really good design
and to be honest planning officers
deserve congratulations
in working with the applicant to come up
with this
um application it's as it's as about as
um
it's going to have less effect than um
many other applications would have done
on that pla
plot in terms of conservation it's an
ideal
a little little um
house that's going to be put there and i
really think it's in keeping
it's a lot better that we've done a lot
of damage to that area in terms of
conservation
in terms of some of the office blocks
that are on the main road there
and this little neighborhood
it's going to be higher than normal
density it's a town center
and i have a lot of sympathy with that i
know it's taking
light away but that's the nature of a
hill to be honest and i really struggle
to see how we can refuse this applicant
because we can't make it better
uh than what's provided and
i think the protection of the screening
and things like that we've looked at
i i i do propose we accept it i realize
that there's going to be a split vote it
may only be me on one side
but um i i support the officer's
recommendation on this one
thank you councillor councillor bigby
i'm going to find it extremely difficult
to add to what dr neil and council
welton have said
um they spoke really eloquently when i
first read this officer's report
um i thought i've got to visit this site
there was something which
made me wish to make every effort
in the present circumstances and i did
and when i visited the site
um i was right you know i couldn't
possibly
support this recommendation i appreciate
the separation distances have been
quoted
but separation distances applied to
properties on the flat
surely not raised up on a hill um i
think the planning committee were right
last time
i think they're perfectly right this
time
if we refuse it
um yes i think if we to ask
this proposed development will certainly
compromise the immunity
the residents of three springfield road
particularly
currently enjoy and we should be able to
continue it
to enjoy um i think it would be
unacceptable
to deprive them of that community
thank you councillor um councilman
morgan
thank you chair um i've really struggled
with this
well i'm sure all the committee members
can feel the same that um
you read some applications and you can
make your decision quite quickly from
just reading the papers and i i visited
um this property uh the neighbors
as well as outside on garden lane um
this morning and i'm really glad i did
um as it's coming to committee um i have
thought about it um i think it's tough
garden lane is a really tough site and i
don't it's difficult to put houses in
there
um i i i i think
the planning team have done a really
good job and this is not a um
it's a difficult place to put houses um
it's it's an odd site i have to be
honest i've lived in ultra come six
years and i
didn't even know this i didn't even know
the road um
and cancer calling mentioned topography
and
you know it is a factor this the garden
is higher
it goes higher than the the house but it
this how that house was built
way before i think anyone on this
committee was uh was alive you know
it's um that is just a factor of it um i
don't think we can just ignore
that and just say well it's tough um
i think that probably there is a little
bit of fear on some of this development
which is probably not quite as founded
um but i i've been looking at this and
we're looking on google maps actually
just now
and um and i always mentioned it's not a
south facing garden
no that's true it's more west facing
than south but it is actually it's
southwest ish to an extent and i've got
a nor i've got a west facing garden
which slightly
this is the north and i know how much in
the summer particularly i
really value those summer nights when it
when it's very manchester to get them
but that you actually see the um see the
sun come down um to the extent that i've
treated my my trees were um not cut down
entirely but i cut some branches off to
get better light
only a few weeks ago and
i honestly i just can't see myself
supporting it i think it's a really good
design
um i i i i agree it's a struggle to see
what else you would build on there
but i don't think this is fair on the
neighbours particularly on number three
um so i will be um very reluctantly
i will be of um voting against officer
recommendations
thank you thank you morgan counselling
minis
point out to members that we are
approaching time
shortly um thank you chair
i won't be long um i i i actually
agree with uh council accordingly that
it is an awkward plot and it's on the
hill
but then you have to work with the plot
you have so
i'm afraid that um putting a two-story
house on a plot that's not really
suitable given the neighbors
is not appropriate so um i will be
voting against officer recommendation
because i don't think it's fair on the
neighbors i'm afraid and you have to
work with what plot you have
thank you very much
thank you councillor administ no other
members have indicated in the chat
i don't think that they wish to speak
and as it stands i
have counsellor jerome moving
a proposal to vote against officer
recommendation and
council accordingly moving the proposal
to vote in line with officer
recommendation
and i haven't recorded any but he's
seconding either proposal though
second against right
do we have to do i have to second for
what might
proposal you don't have to counter no i
know i don't have to but
do we need a second of sarah if we do
i second it right
um okay so
counselor will be moved to second
against
it counselor i can know you've moved to
second in favor
councillor hartley you've indicated in
the chat that you'd like to speak
can you yeah i'm sorry i'll be i'll be
brief chair
i i think i think it is a really um
difficult application i agree with what
a lot of what counselor
accordingly said so i think the key
issue is um
well miss cole is just just stolen my
thunder really is
is what i'm struggling with is is the
planning grounds
to reject the officer recommendation so
i think the
parking and the highway safety i think i
think the as is situation
you could have that issue so if somebody
were to bring the house back into use
and uh and park the car on the site you
would still potentially have that same
issue of vehicles sort of entering and
exiting the property
so uh i'm not sure that's a planning
reason to refuse
this application uh the separation
distances and and the overlooking
if the screening is is put in place and
that is
adhered to um which is in the conditions
and there's also a condition about the
roof lights on the eastern elevation
being obscured
glazed then those measures would prevent
um
prevent the overlooking which i know the
um the speaker was was
very concerned about so the sole issue
which
which i can i can understand why it is
concerning is is the height of the
building and the height of the
of the of the ridge height in particular
it does sort of double the
you know the roof height that you can
that you can see from the guns on
springfield road
um so i suppose echo what miss curly
said you know we'd need reasons to
refuse and i'm not sure i think that's
the only basis
that that still has some merit in
planning terms but i'm not sure
that is enough grounds to refuse thank
you chair
thank you councillor in terms of voting
can i
just be reminded the motion we take
first
is the opposite motion chairman so the
motion to refuse which is why we need
the reasons
okay um as i
understand it from what members have
said they're concerned about
the height of the building contained
within the application and the impact
that that would have
on residential immunity of neighboring
properties
um and also in terms of
just the development being overbearing
you're capable of articulating this
better than i am
no i've i've heard the same um chairman
um and yes we
we could turn that into a into a reason
for for refusal
um i have heard concerns about highway
safety i would
very much advise against that as a
reason for refusal on the basis that
there is
a dwelling on the site now so there is a
full back position
um but again i've only heard that from
one or two members
um so um but
so i think we just need we just need um
some indication that that that the vote
would be on that one reason for reviews
or the over
the overview
or they want additional reasons
the motion to refuse contrary to officer
recommendation
um on the basis of the reasons that
we'll just discuss with miss coley
i'll move through the members now
councillor rigby refused
thank you counselor counselor jerome
get cancer with jerome are you can you
hear me sorry
yeah refusal thank you councillor
councillor aren't we
uh adverts refuse as well chair
thank you councillor councilman
i'll be voting to refuse the application
thank you
thank you councillor councillor proctor
yeah refuse as well thank you councillor
council accordingly voting against
refusal
sure thank you council councillor curry
refusal please chairman thank you
councillor councillor akanova
voting against refusal
thank you councillor councillor morgan
for refusal thank you
councillor council of acting
yeah i'm i'm um against refusal so i
support the officer's recommendations
thank you councillor councillor dr
berkley
voting for refusal of the application
thank you councillor and i shall also
vote for refusal
i make that eight votes
in line with what was proposed which is
to vote against
officer recommendation and three votes
um
to the contrary um i make it 9-3
chairman because there are um 12. i make
it nine i
i can't count sorry thank you ms conley
um i think we'll probably have time for
the meeting now
so can we just remind members present of
the
date for the deferred meeting the the
outstanding applications sorry
yes we'll we will reconvene on tuesday
um
coming which i think is the 2s
6th um time to be agreed perhaps if you
close the meeting
chairman we can agree that that time
between us